tout associé à un club l'AS
Saint-Étienne l'ange vert se raconte
dans un livre foot sentimental et il se
raconte aussi ici Dominique Rochet est
notre invité dans un monde un regard les
entretiens de Public Sénat un monde un
regard vendredi prochain à 17h30 sur
public
[Musique]
Séna
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur les
chaînes parlementaires pour une émission
spéciale consacrée à la grande marche
civique contre l'antisémitisme l'appel a
été lancé en début de semaine par la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale yel
brun Pivet et le président du Sénat
Gérard Larcher initiative inédite pour
réveiller les consciences face à la
recrudescence des actes antisémites
depuis le 7 octobre date du massacre du
Hamas en Israël le cortège partira de la
place des Invalides juste derrière
l'Assemblée nationale à 15h direction le
Sénat une déambulation qui devrait durer
un peu plus d'une heure alors pour vous
faire vivre cet événement toutes nos
équipes se mobilisent dans quelques
instants une interview exclusive de Yael
brun Pivet et Gérard Larcher avec Elsa
mondinava pour les chaînes
parlementaires et vous retrouverez
également dans le cortège Quentin Calmet
avec les responsables de gauche et
Stéphanie des piierres au côté du
rassemblement national alors justement
on va vous retrouver Quentin Calmet
puisque vous êtes place des Invalides
d'où va partir cette manifestation à 15h
est-ce que les Français ont répondu à
l'appel de yel brun Pivet et de Gérard
Larcher
ouis bonjour Brigitte bonjour Tam
effectivement la mobilisation c'est la
question des prochaines minutes
prochaines heures avec un un accessoire
indispensable hein même si là il y a une
petite acalmie c'est le parapluie parce
qu'il pleut des cordes à Paris le
cortège qui va partir d'ici place des
Invalides passer par le Quai d'Orsay
pour ensuite rejoindre le boulevard
Saint-Michel le boulevard Saint-Germain
tout d'abord pour arriver au Sénat ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'URA 25
ministres présents dans le cortège
parisien une dizaine d'autres ministres
seront présents en région tous les
partis politiques à Paris sont
représentés à l'exception de la France
insoumise quant à la gauche PS PCF et
écologiste elle va défiler derrière une
banderole commune contre l'antisémitisme
et tous les fauteurs de haine et de
racisme la gauche qui tient un point
presse dans une quinzaine de minutes
qu'on va pouvoir suivre merci merci
beaucoup Quentin pour toutes ces
explications on vous retrouve bien vite
tout au long de cette cette émission
également avec nous Stéphanie des
pierres Stéphanie vous êtes vous en
queue de cortège également Place des
Invalides c'est là que le rassemblement
national s'est donné
rendez-vous je suis en fait dans la
diagonale opposée à à Quentin et à la
gauche sur cette eslanate des Invalides
légèrement en dehors du périmètre nous
attendons Marine Le Pen et ses troupes
au moins une quarantaine de députés
seront présents il devrait arriver vers
14h45 et puis c'est aussi ici sur cette
petite place Salvador ALND le lieu de
rendez-vous des partisans d'éc Zemmour
ensuite ils devraient tous rejoindre le
cortège mais vous le voyez on est assez
loin on est à 1 km de la tête de
corortège qui sera devant l'Assemblée
nationale merci Stéphanie des piierr on
vous retrouvera bien sûr tout au long de
cette émission alors pour nous
accompagner maintenant en plateau voici
nos invités Jonathan Ayoun merci d'être
avec nous bonjour vous êtes auteur
réalisateur de la série documentaire
histoire de l'antisémitisme diffusé en
ce moment sur
Judit cens Solal bonjour Merci vous êtes
psychanalyste auteur et esséiste et on
vous doit avec Jonathan Ayoun le bouquin
de l'humour juif chez bouquin édition
également avec nous Pascal Perino
bonjour bonjour politologue et
professeur à Scien Po Paris et également
sur ce plateau Émilie zapalski bonjour
vous êtes communicante et éditorialiste
politique alors Pascal Perino il y a
trois fois plus d'actes antisémites qui
ont été recensés depuis le 7 octobre
depuis ce massacre du Hamas en Israël en
en quelques semaines trois fois plus que
sur l'ensemble de l'année 2022 est-ce
que ça appelait justement à ce sursaut
républicain oui c'est un sinistre record
auquel on assiste depuis le massacre
perpétré par le Hamas le 7 octobre
jamais on avait connu en un temps aussi
court une inflation d'acte
antisémite cela veut dire en effet que
l'antisémitisme fait retour pas
simplement j'allais dire dans les
paroles mais dans le passage à l'acte
hein il faut bien distinguer les deux
parce que sinon on peut se rassurer se
rassurer à trop bon compte d'autre part
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
pourquoi si tard le massacre a été
perpétré il y a un mois et là nous
sommes un mois après et enfin
pourrait-on dire il y a une marche qui
avait été organisé à l'initiative du
CRIF mais pas pas de marche à
l'initiative des institution si vous
voulez euh l'ampleur du massacre
perpétré euh les 40 français qui ont été
assassinés tout cela méritait que la
France la société française la classe
politique française se mobilise et se
isse à la hauteur de l'événement elle a
tardé et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que le spectacle du moins que la
classe politique a donné depuis une
semaine n'est vraiment pas à la hauteur
de l'événement c'est une indignation Mor
polémique effectivement politique mais
un mot encore sur le fait
qu'effectivement Jud il a eu plus d'un
millier d'actes antisémites en quelques
semaines on voit donc les institutions
qui se mobilisent c'est important aussi
que les citoyens se mobilisent dire que
l'antisémitisme c'est l'affaire de tous
aujourd'hui alors évidemment
l'antisémitisme ça ne peut pas être que
l'affaire des Juifs et donc l'affaire
des victimes et s'il y a un décalage à
la limite on peut comprendre qu'il y a
un décalage parce que on pourrait faire
la différence entre ce qui le massacre
du 7 octobre et qui a eu évidemment pour
victime aussi des citoyen français pour
lequel il aurait fallu sans doute se
mobiliser auparavant mais par ailleurs
je pense que c'est très important de
garder le caractère français de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui il y a de
l'antisémitisme en France et je pense
que il est dangereux de corréler les
événements alors que on nous force à à
penser que
notamment multiplication depuis le le 7
octobre ça a pris une ampleur inédite le
fait qu'il y ait une multiplication et
qu'il y ait des gens qui envie
d'importer justement le conflit ou de
trouver prétexte à ce conflit pour
exprimer antisémitisme latant ou des
préjugés ou sa'autoriser des choses il
n'empêche que l'antisémitisme se passe
sur le territoire français et qu'on a à
gérer cette situation pas seulement sur
le territoire français on pourrait y
revenir partout en Europe là on peut
dire qu'ici il faut se rappeler que
c'est un combat à mener pour tous les
citoyens français et pas seulement pour
ceux qui seraient concernés justement
par un conflit qui est quand même à 3500
km et que il faut absolument entendre
que ce combat est est spécifique ici
aussi et on ne peut pas entendre des
phrases comme certains ont pu dire que
manifester contre l'antisémitisme ça
voudrait dire soutenir des massacres de
population c'est
c'est pensez que il va va y avoir ce
réveil républicain est-ce que vous
l'espérez en tout cas aujourd'hui
l'espéz bien évidemment appréhendez le
moment que nous allons vivre ensemble
dans dans dans quelques minutes je peux
pas le nier il y a il y a cette
inquiétude parce que depuis le début des
années 2000 à chaque fois qu'il y a des
pics d'antisémitisme il y a un sursaut
malgré tout d'une partie de la société
française des manifestation mais elles
sont avec le temps de moins en moins
rassembleuses alors là vu l'initiative
qui VI d'ailleurs de de des deux
chambres peut-être que cela va entraîner
une mobilisation plus grande vu le
caractère aussi inédit de ce pic de
cette flambée d'antisémitisme qui est
beaucoup plus importante que toutes les
fois depuis les années 2000 et qui a
aussi pour spécificité et je tenais
aussi à à à à le rappeler euh deux
événements qui qui qui qui s'ajoutent le
premier c'est le conflit au ProcheOrient
en effet depuis les années 2000 à chaque
fois qu'il y a un conflit au
ProcheOrient il y a une montée des actes
antisémites en France mais la deuxième
chose c'est qu'aussi il y a d'autres
moments où il y a une montée des des
actes antisémites en France c'est
lorsqu'il y a un antisémitisme meurtrier
d'ailleurs meurtrier sur notre sol et là
c'est pas sur notre sol c'est en Israël
mais avec des Français juifs notamment
qui sont pris pour cible et des
Israéliens juifs qui sont pris pour
cible en tant que juifs et donc là il y
a un antisémitisme meurtrier qui a ses
vie plus un conflit au Proche Orient qui
a suivi et la somme des deux fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a un pic inédit et
donc on devrait avoir un sursaut inédit
aussi dans S votre inquiétude en tout
cas sur cette mobilisation aujourd'hui
oui bah pourquoi L- contre
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui c'est moins
rassembleur quiier ce que vous semblez
dire bah je je je j'ai l'impression
parce qu'il y a une banalisation de
l'antisémitisme parce qu'il y a en effet
depuis maintenant plus de 20 ans un
nombre d'actes assez incalculable enfin
calculé mais qui ne cesse d'augmenter à
chaque fois qu'il y a un passage à
l'acte terrible parce qu'en fait c'est
ce qui est aussi le plus bouleversant
c'est que la montée des actes
antisémites suivent toujours un moment
effroyable un meurtre un un passage à
l'acte criminel et ça autorise ça libère
une parole et des actes en effet pas
qu'une parole mais et des actes et qu'à
ce momentl on peut se dire en fait la
mobilisation va être très grande et on a
peur parce qu'on a aussi la référence
fait référence à 1990 à la manifestation
après la
profanation du caré juif de Carpentra et
après ce momentl il y a une mobilisation
assez bouleversante et notamment pour
les français très forte mobilisation
près de 200000
personnes président de la République et
et donc les Français juifs ne se sont
pas sentis seul à ce moment-là mais à ce
moment-là c'est pas pour minimiser la
gravité de l'événement mais on s'en est
pris à des tombes juives là on s'en
prend à des individus en vie normalement
la mobilisation devrait être plus grande
et elle ne l'est pas Émilie zapalsky la
polémique politique qui a enflé autour
de de cette marche peut peut freiner
selon vous la mobilisation aujourd'hui
c'est possible ça va pas décourager des
citoyens qui ont envie de venir je pense
mais c'est vrai que ça a été un un
spectacle assez lamentable mais il me
semble qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
maladresse à la fois sur la position
affichée par rapport au conflit si on
parle du conflit et de ce que ça peut
provoquer comme passage à l'acte
antisémite il y a eu beaucoup de
maladresses de ce côté-là je vais
m'expliquer et beaucoup de maladresse
aussi dans l'affichage de cette
manifestation de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme parce qu'on a
l'impression que hier se jouit une
partie avec les manifestation qui ser
les Palestiniens et Gaza et aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que les deux
s'opposent quelque part c'est aussi le
positionnement du gouvernement qui a été
très maladroit parce qu'il a été plutôt
proisraélien en tout cas on a entendu de
la de la voix de y Bron PIV elle-même un
soutien inconditionnel à Israël avec un
rééquilibrage mais ça veut dire que le
message n'est pas clair aujourd'hui à se
rassemblé pour la République et contre
l'antisémitisme c'est ce qu'on verra
tout à l'heure sur les B Emmanuel Macron
a essayé de rééquilibrer avec ce en même
temps qui pour une fois il me semble est
plus souhaitable que jamais autant dans
d'autres domaines je trouve que ça
fonctionne pas du tout autant là d'à la
fois dire on est en soutien aux Juifs de
France aux israéliens qui ont subi cette
horrible attaque du Hamas terroriste et
on est en en soutient au peuple de Gaza
qui est en train de subir une situation
et sur le plan humanitaire qui est pas
tolérable c'est audible ça pour vous ce
que c sauf que ça vient trop tardivement
et qu'on a eu une espèce de
positionnement on comprend parce qu'il y
avait le choc de cette attaque
terroriste mais on a Emmanuel Macron a
cherché à rééquilibrer ce que je trouve
dommage franchement c'est qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne vienne pas dans les rang de
cette manifestation justement pour
porter cette voix équilibrée qu'il
essaie de faire à travers la lettre de
ce matin dans le Parisien en
de faire hier entien au peuple de Gaza
en disant qu' vaugmenter l'aideire et
qu'il faut tout faire et même avec cette
parole très forte qu' a eu en disant
Israël n'a aucune raison et aucuneé
légitimité pour ses bombardements civils
on entend peu cette voix qui fait que de
manifestation comme celle d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui ne doivent pas s'opposer
et je pense que c'est ça aussi qui
freine parce qu'on a l'impression que en
venant à la manifestation d'aujourd'hui
c'est comme si on choisissait son
opinion qu'on choisissait de quel côté
on se range ce qui exérable parce que on
doit pouvoir avoir cette position et il
me semble que celui qui pour une fois le
maître du en même temps pouvait faire ce
lienlà c'était Emmanuel Macron et
dernière parole il pouvait aussi passer
en avant parce que comme vous l'avez dit
quand même dans les rangs du fond on va
avoir quand même des formations qui de
fait historiqu sont antisémites et
xénophobe parce que c'est vrai que leur
xénophobie allait passer des Juifs aux
musulmans ça les arrange bien d'être là
et même encore antisémite ça vous avez
raison et et ça je trouve que la parole
d'Emmanuel Macron aurait permis
probablement d'avoir bah la République
euh ce fameux arc républicain dont moi
il me semble qu'ils ne font pas partie
ceux qui seront présents dans les rang
ça aurait donné une force un petit peu
plus importante Pascal Perino Eric cotti
a dit c'est une faute que le Président
de la République ne soit pas là
aujourd'hui à cette marche vous êtes
d'accord avec lui oui c'est une
maladresse parce que si vous voulez le
président de la République c'est plus
qu'Emmanuel Macron hein la fonction de
la président de la République c'est de
représenter l'unité de la nation dans
toute sa diversité de l'extrême droite à
extrême gauche et si le président avait
été au premier rang de cette
manifestation comme l'avait été François
mitéran en 1990 comme l'avait été
François Hollande en 2015 ça aurait été
un symbole tout à fait utile et je crois
que oui d'une certaine manière c'est une
erreur comment vous l'analysez du coup
cette absence c'est aussi lié à cette
polémique politique que l'on a vu monter
tout au long de cette semaine l'idée de
pas vouloir se mélanger effectivement à
cette polémique oui je crois que en
effet il y a peut-être ce souci de ne
pas se mélanger à ce spectacle mais
quelque part pitoyable que beaucoup de
partis ont offert mais quelque part s'il
était sur le pavé parisien aujourd'hui
serurait peut-être effacé
ce voilà assez pitoyable d'autre part
c'est si vous voulez les limites du en
même temps hein au fond avec ce souci de
maintenir les deux plateaux de la
balance totalement égal bien sûr qu'il
faut avoir une vision équilibrée ça ne
veut pas dire que une fois qu'on a
soutenu Israël faut soutenir
inconditionnellement si vous voulez les
mouvements de de de population à Gaza et
cetera c'est je veux dire il y a
pas et chez Emmanuel Macron c'est depuis
le début l'ambiguïé il a l'impression
qu'il peut maintenir un équilibre entre
les deux positions en étant comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure très
proisraélien on lui demandait peut-être
pas autant au début et après très
proalestinien on lui demandait peut-être
pas autant à la fin ça rend la position
du président de la République à mon avis
totalement isé je dis sol c'est ça qui
explique aujourd'hui que le Président de
la République ne soit pas dans le dans
le cortège déjà il faut quand même
remarquer que même nous sommes tentés de
revenir à cette question proisraélien
proalestinien donc on continue
inconsciemment en tout cas à considérer
que aller à une manifestation avec des
Juifs parce que c'est avec des Juifs
finalement il va y avoir des Juifs dans
dans cette manifestation donc all à une
manifestation contre l'antisémitisme en
France ça voudrait dire qu'on soutient
Israël et que de l'autre côté il
faudrait aller donc soutir israë ou la
politique de Benjamin netanah c'est ça
derrière mess même le fait de soutenir
Israël si on lutte contre
l'antisémitisme en France un phénomène
qui a eu des effets bien avant la
création de l'État d'Israël
malheureusement sur notre territoire
aussi on n'a pas normalement à faire cet
amalgame ou en tout cas cette
association d'idé on n'y échappe pas et
je pense que justement c'est
problématique parce que on doit pouvoir
venir manifester contre l'antisémitisme
cont soit proisraélien ou proalestinien
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
parce que Emmanuel Macron dans sa lettre
a dit qu'il soit religieux social
identitaire ou racial l'antisémitisme
est toujours tel que le représentait
Émile Zola au dieux tandis que pardon on
voit cette image de la gauche avec vous
le voyez marine Tondelier Olivier fort
et Fabien Rousel les trois responsables
de gauche du Parti socialiste de LV du
Parti communiste qui commence à défiler
on voit également le sénateur communiste
Yan brossa juste derrière et donc cette
partie de la gauche qui a souhaité
pouvoir défiler avec un cordon sanitaire
ce sont leurs mots vis-à-vis du
rassemblement nationalordon voilà juste
donc oui je revenais à ma question le
fait que Emmanuel Macron a voulu donc se
référer à l'affaire drefus c'est dire
que pour lui il voulait dire attention
antisémitisme c'est aussi ça et donc ne
pas le lier à Israël à la situation
actuelle et cetera sans doute mais le
fait qu'il ne vienneent pas c'est bien
parce que il ne veut pas que ça soit
associé à une manifestation
pro-israélenne ou en tout cas qu'on
l'accuse de ça et que demain ils doivent
donc aller à l'autre manifestation
propalestinienne par ailleurs je pense
que on a on a peut-être oublié mais on a
pendant le confinement le on a aussi
même pendant les gilets jaunes beaucoup
attaqué Macron comme président des Juifs
vendu aux Juifs enfin il a été victime
d'antisémitisme si l'on peut dire est-ce
que est-ce que il n'a pas voulu à
nouveau être
associé avec cette idée là des Juifs et
que ça serait le président des Juifs
Juifs argent tout ça alors jathan aon
est-ce que pour vous cette lettre au
français c'est un prétexte du président
de la République pour ne pas se rendre
aujourd'hui à la manifestation c'était
entre c'était la moindre des chose qu'il
qu'il écrive quelque chose pour
expliquer pourquoi il ne vient pas
j'aurais préféré qu'il éccrive qu'il
s'adresse au français après la marche
parce que le message combien même les
propos sont justes qubien même les
propos sont forts qubien même il vient
rappeler l'histoire de l'antisémitisme
sur notre territoire le fait de dire
d'annoncer avant une marche qu' ne s'y
rend pas et ben ça peut aussi décourager
beaucoup de Français de s'y rendre il
n'avait pas besoin personne il y avait
pas d'injonction à dire qu'il ne prenait
pas part à cette marche quand François
mitteron a été à celle 19 1990 après la
profanation du cimetière juif de du
carré juif du cimetière de Carpentra il
nit avit pas dit qu'il venait ça été la
surprise et ça a été d'ailleurs une
belle surprise pour tous ceux qui
étaient là et ça adresse un message
d'espoir même après très fort là quelque
part moi je faisais partie de ceux qui
attendaient à ce qu'il ne se prononce
pas mais est-ce qu'on découvre pour ceux
qui marchaient après qu'il était là
qu'il avait rejoint la marche enfin mais
il a annoncé qu'ils ne viennent pas
quand bien même les mots sont justes le
geste est plus fort émilieapelskis ça
veut dire qu'il y aura pas ce ce
mouvement historique aujourd'hui ça
aurait pu être un rendez-vous historique
l'absence du président de la République
fait que ça ne le sera pas bah ça sera
moins et on le dit nous-même parce que
90 2015 c'est vrai que d'avoir dans les
rangs on va voir Nicolas Sarkozi on va
voir François Hollande pourquoi on n'
pas Emmanuel Macron qui est quand même
responsable de l'unité de la cohésion du
pays et moi ce qui me choque aussi c'est
que dans sa lettre justement il explique
que c'est parce que il est responsable
de cette unité du pays qui n'y va pas ça
cautionne un peu cette idée que vous
avez dit Judit que si on participe à une
marche contre l'antisémitisme c'est
parce que on est pro-israélien ou pro
gouvernement Benjamin netanahou je je
pense que c'est dommage qu'il cautionne
qu'il aille dans ce sens-là moi il me
semble que c'est un rêve de dire que on
pourra pas importer le conflit
israëlopalestinien on a la plus grande
communauté juive d'Europe on a une
grande population de musulmans moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est voilà c'est de
facto importé mais qu'on se qu'on essaie
de pas se disputer auprès de ça c'est
aussi la responsabilité du président
j'allais dire c'est c'est un peu trop
léger pour cette situation mais presque
de siffler la fin de la récréation en
disant attention on peut être à la fois
dans une manifestation contre les actes
antisémites parce que c'est
insupportable d'avoir 1000 1040 actes
donc trois fois
plus c'est catastrophique c'est
inacceptable et on peut être dans les
rang des soutiens de la population de
Gaza moi je parle pas des agissements et
de de la révolution mais je parle de
soutien de ces personnes qui sont en
train de souffrir le martyre et qui ont
pas d'aide humanitaire ou très peu on
peut et cette position équilibrée il il
était capable de l'incarner je je vous
dis c'est vrai que cet équilibre du en
même temps il est toujours un peu
bizarreou et là il aurait eu l'occasion
de le donner et de l'affirmer et il me
semble qu'il y a eu un glissement quand
même depuis le début du conflit vers une
position un peu plus équilibrée mais là
c'était l'occasion aujourd'hui de
l'affirmer pleinement de dire pleinement
qu'on qu'on on n pas à s'opposer dans
ces deux luttes là qu' qu'elles sont
complémentaires et pas opposables et ça
c'est important parce que ça va créer
beaucoup de fractures ça va créer
beaucoup de déchirur il parce qu' Perino
le président de la République avait dit
il faut éviter à tout prix l'importation
du conflit c'est finalement un peu
l'échec d'Emmanuel Macron c'est pas
l'échec d'Emmanuel Macron il est
impossible que le conflit ne s'importe
pas hein voilà on le voit dans toutes
les grandes démocraties du monde il y a
des manifestations
propalestinienne il y a des
manifestations de soutien à Israël et
cetera donc voilà c'est c'est un rêve
irininique que le en effet ça ne
s'importe pas en France surtout qu' il
faut bien voir ce qui se passe tout de
même sur le terrain
israélien ce que l'on voit à l'œuvre en
Israël c'est à nouveau l'idée de la part
de cette certaines forces issu du
mouvement palestinien de voir Israël
disparaître à nouveau vous savez les
slogans qui sont au premier rang de
nombreuses manifestations palestinienne
c'est du jourdant à la mer un seul État
ça veut dire fin d'Israël donc forcément
il y a à la fois dans ces manifestations
le soutien aux Juifs de France et le
soutien et l'attachement de la France à
un état qui est l'état d'Israël pérenne
alors ensuite un État d'Israël au côté
d'un État palestinien dans quelles
conditions c'est la fameuse réflexion
qu'on aura peut-être un jour à nouveau
sur les deux États mais quand on discute
avec nos amis israéliens c'est très
frappant de voir moi je suis frappé les
quelques contact que j'ai eu avec des
collègues israéliens qu'il soit de
gauche ou de droite voz c'est pas du
tout le problème ils disent on a
véritablement l'impression qu'on joue
maintenant notre avenir est-ce que
l'antisionisme est un antisémitisme
aujourd'hui pour vous Judit Coren Solal
est-ce qu'il faut que il y a un chiffre
il y a un signe égal entre les deux cont
tenu du fait que bah l'État d'Israël
aujourd'hui il existe et donc le nier
est-il un antisémitisme en fait
l'antisionisme c'est un c'est vraiment
un maualise on met ce qu'on veut
derrière parce que antiionisme si le
sionisme c'est croire que il y a une
légitimité à l'existence de l'État
d'Israël bien oui l'antisionisme est un
antisémitisme ça voudrait dire qu'on
refuse à un peuple ce qu'on accepte pour
tous les autres c'est pas ce que vous
mettez derrière l'antisionisme non mais
bien sûr c'est ce que je dis mais il y a
beaucoup de gens par contre qui ne
mettent pas ça il y a beaucoup de gens
qui pensent que antisioniste c'est être
contre le fait
que Politi israélien gouvernement ou de
l'UT cont les colonies ou chose un
mélange on bouge plus on bouge plus cé
on peut d'ailleurs on peut voir ça aussi
parce que nous-même nous nous disons
d'un côté il y a les musulmans ou la
population musulmane qui soutient les
Palestiniens et de l'autre côté il y les
Juifs qui soutiennent Israël en fait ça
n'est même pas si clair que ça
c'est-à-dire que il y a beaucoup de de
citoyens musulmans en France qui sont
contre le Hamas parce que on oublie
aussi que on ne parle pas que des
populations palestiniennes qu'on est en
train ici de de voir devant nos yeux une
opération du Hamas lequel Hamas décrié
par aussi une partie de ça bien faire la
différence entre le Hamas et l'Autorité
palestinienne ou le peuple palestinien
il y a beaucoup de choses il y a
beaucoup de de Juifs qui qui soutiennent
ou qui pensent qu'ils sont pro
Palestiniens donc déjà mettre prendre
comme quelque chose d'établi que bon ben
les Juifs sont antipalestiniens en
quelque sorte et que les tous les
musulmans sont proalestiniens donc
antiionistes ça ça ça ne recouvre pas
une réelle réalité par contre ça arrange
tout le monde toutes ces choses
diichotomi qui font que finalement on ne
vient pas donne des excuses finalement
pour ne pas se rendre aujourd'hui à
cette manifestation Parel Pino vouliit
ajouter quelque chose oui d'ailleurs il
faut pas simplement parler
d'antisionisme si vous voulez ce dont on
se en compte on aurait jamais dû
l'oublier c'est que l'antisémitisme il
est fort à l'extrême droite mais il
n'est pas l'apanage de la seule extrême
droite il y a un antisémitisme
historique à gauche et en particulier à
l'extrême gauche de blanquy au 19e
siècle jusqu'à Monsieur David guireud
sinistre député qui vient de faire une
sortie d'un antisémitisme délirant à
Tunis vous avez un continuum oui il y a
un antisémitisme dans une partie de la
gauche et dans le refus d'fi de
s'associer à cela il y a cet élément qui
est aussi à l'œeuvre et puis il y a
peut-être Émilie zapalski aussi le vote
des Juifs aujourd'hui vers qui se tourn
les les personnes de confession juifes
aujourd'hui quand il s'agit d'aller
voter oui après je sais pas s'il faut
pareil être sur des réflexions aussi
mécanique de d'électoralisme qui qui
sont là puisque vous avez parlé d' LFI
il y a aussi cette idé de dans la
position à l'invers ENF à l'inverse en
tout cas l'électorat musulman et
notamment dans les quartiers on sait
toute cette démarche je sais pas s'il
faut être cynique et probablement il le
sont suffisamment pour nous moi ce que
je trouve difficile aussi dans cette
manifestation c'est le positionnement
des uns et des autres et vous l'avez dit
et je pense que ça peut rebuter d'aller
manifester moi clairement manifester à
côté de responsable d'extrême droite que
ça soit Marion maréchal Marine Le Pen ou
Eric Zemour avec leur passé historique
et leurs fondamentaux qui sont toujours
là quoi qu'il en soit je trouve que
c'est très compliqué et je trouve que ça
a été très maladroit de ne pas voir
venir ce jeu parce que là ce qu'on
entend c'est une communication alors
très réussie hein très belle très très
vierge de tout antisémitisme et
xénophobie de Marine Le Pen notamment
qui se fait la chantre la défenseuse
finalement des Juifs on entend quand
même la petite petite musique derrière
que c'est la défense des Juifs et c'est
l'opposition à l'immigration musulmane
derrière et on a ça donc c'est quand
même très compliqué de participer à ça
même si on les a mis en COD de peloton
j'ai entendu hier Sandrine Rousseau qui
disait donc des écologistes députés de
Paris qui disait moi je participe mais
je vais être au début faire les
déclarations et après je veux pas
manifester c'est compliqué quand même je
trouve ça d'autant plus qu'il y a quand
même des signaux inquiétants qui se
passent au Sénat sur le projet de loi
immigration on a quand même l'autorité
le l'aide médicale d'État qui vient
d'être supprimé alors c'est que le début
je l'espè devrait être établi lors du
passage à l'Assemblée mais quand même
c'est inquiétant l'article 3 qui
prévoyait aussi la régularisation des
des personnes sans papi qui sont sur des
métiers en tenstion d'ailleurs j'ai vu
que pour l'aide médicale à l'état il y a
déjà des médecins qui disent de toute
façon quoi qu'il arrive nous on ira
c'est des signaux inquiétants ce que je
veux dire c'est que chacun y met son
interprétation et et c'est ça qui est
délicat et encore une fois une parole un
petit peu du chef là-haut et ben qui qui
qui permettrait de faire groupe ou alors
qui serait un petit peu plus forte
qu'une lettre envoyée justement en
disant je suis en pensé avec vous je
suis de tout cœur avec vous ça aurait
été un peu plus fort oui tandis que l'on
continue à à suivre le début de cette
manifestation et on voit notamment et
bien la gauche he derrière une bande
rollle qui est en train de se mettre en
place un point presse est prévu d'ici
quelques minutes vous voyez notamment
Olivier fort vous voyez marine Tondelier
vous voyez Fabien Roussel le parti
socialiste
ELV le Parti communiste qui sont en
train de se mettre en place en vue
effectivement d'une prise de parole que
vous pourrez voir bien sûr d'ici
quelques minutes dès que tout le monde
sera prêt mais pour l'instant nous
allons voir nous allons aller voir
Stéphanie des pierres qui suit elle et
bien le cortège du rassemblement
national Stéphanie pour un point sur la
situation actuellement où en
êtes-vous vous le voyez derrière al moi
la place commence à se remplir il a des
militants du rassemblement national il y
a des militants zmouristes et puis
quelques personnalités du rassemblement
national les députés Jocelin Dey
michaell taverne vient d'arriver Marine
Le Pen devrait arriver vers
14h45 a priori une au moins une
quarantaine de députés du rassemblement
national se seront ici et devraient
rejoindre ensuite le cortège merci
Stéphanie des piierre pour ces
précisions et on va pouvoir rejoindre
donc la gauche qui est réunie place des
Invalides pour un cordon républain face
au rassemblement national on écoute
marine telier pour toute la semaine
évidemment que c'est désastreux d'avoir
des polémiques sur ce genre de sujet qui
devrait nous rassembler évidemment que
la participation du rassemblement
national à ses marches trouble
énormément et nous-même nous sommes
troublé c'est pas un plaisir que de
participer au même rassemblement surtout
sur ce sujet évidemment mais il nous
semblait que notre place était ici et
que la descence le respect les aurait
invité eux à ne pas venir le
rassemblement national est un parti qui
a été fondé par des va F SS dont le
président a encore dit dimanche dernier
que Jean-Marie Le Pen n'avait pas de
problème avec l'antisémitisme alors
qu'il a quand même été condamné
plusieurs fois pour négationnisme
reconquête est un parti dont le
président Éric Zemour a été condamné
plusieurs fois aussi pour un jeu racial
c'est che chez eux ils appelleraient ça
du multirécidivisme donc ils sont en
fait les spécialistes et donc oui c'est
très déstabilisant d'avoir à marcher
dans la même manifestation queeux c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous ne voulions
pas leur laisser la place ce n'était pas
à nous de partir c'était à eux et donc
nous avons organisé avec le Parti
communiste avec le Parti socialiste avec
beaucoup de partis politiques qui nous
ont rejoint avec aussi des associatifs
j'en vois à mes côtés d'ailleurs vous
pourriez laisser une petite place au
président de l'ldh qui est étouffé par
le
service et donc voilà nous sommes
nombreux aujourd'hui on est très fier de
participer à cette marche on est très
fier d'organiser notre propre cortège
contre contre l'antisémitisme et toutes
les formes il y a un problème vous avez
l'air très donc on est très fier
d'organiser ce cortège contre
l'antisémitisme et contre toutes les
formes de haine et de racisme je pense
que le message est clair beaucoup de
d'habitants de républicains de militants
de citoyens avaient envie de pouvoir
venir à cette marche sans mettre les
leur pas dans les pas du rassemblement
national le cortège que nous avons
organisé va le leur permettre et je
pense que c'est salutaire VO de notre
présence que va sûment compléter Fabien
puis Olivier il a eu quelques u tout à
l'heure quand
pas exprimer
encore moi j'espère que ici on arrivera
à tous manifester ensemble contre
l'antisémitisme et toutes les formes de
racisme sans
provocation et avec beaucoup de
sincérité et comme l'a dit marine c'est
vrai que le fait que des personnalités
politiques ont été condamnées pour
antisémitisme membres de formation
politique qui ont pu contester même
l'existence de la
choix n'est pas normal malgré tout nous
nous avons fait le choix d'être là pour
nous c'est clair pour nous il y a pas
d'ambigué et c'est pour ça que nous
avons fait le choix de défiler ensemble
avec une dizaine d'organisations
politiques progressistes et beaucoup
d'associations qui ont aussi voulu et
manifester et montrer dire ensemble que
les organisations racistes ou les propos
antisémites n'avaient pas de place dans
cette
manifestation
[Musique]
bon à mon tour je veux dire notre sens
de notre présence il y a aujourd'hui des
actes antisémite qui se multiplie il un
conflit au ProcheOrient dont sont rendus
responsables certains Français juifs
alors que ils n'ont pas être tenu pour
comptable de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en Israël et en Palestine il y a une
folie à laissé en fait sintroduire dans
notre pays un conflit qui est un conflit
territorial et qui ne peut pas être
essentialisé on peut être juif sans
soutenir le gouvernement netanahou on
peut être d'origine ou arabe sans pour
autant soutenir le Hamas c'est une
évidence et donc nous sommes venus
rappeler aujourd'hui queantisémitisme ne
peut pas avoir sa place dans la
République mais nous sommes venus aussi
dire que il ne peut pas y avoir de
séparation entre le combat contre
l'antisémitisme et le combat contre le
racisme le combat contre le racisme ne
se divise pas on ne peut pas utiliser
l'entil enfin l'antisé l'antisémitisme
ou plutôt le combat contre
l'antisémitisme pour en faire un combat
raciste contre les Français d'origine
arabo- mususulmane et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous défilons
effectivement avec la gauche avec les
organisations de gauche avec les
associations les associations
antiracistes qui ont fait ce choix de
vouloir manifester par leur présence de
ne pas laisser la place à l'extrême
droite mais pour autant se distinguer et
ne pas marcher côte à côte parce que n
avons en réalité rien enen partage voilà
al dire un mot en tant que président de
de SOS Racisme si nous sommes ici c'est
évidemment en soutien aux Français juifs
qui sont plongés dans la tourmente
depuis le 7 octobre avec une explosion
du nombre d'actes antisémite et je dois
dire qu'il n'est pas normal d'être dans
un pays dans lequel lorsque l'on est
juif on doiv cacher saakipa ou saesusa
nous devons vivre dans un pays dans
lequel chacun quel que soit sa religion
sa culture son origine ne peut pas avoir
peur de ce qu'il est ou de ce qu'il
pratique nous voyons bien que cette
manifestation ça a été rappelée a été s
par la présence de l'extrême droite qui
a créé des polémiques depuis plusieurs
jours pour faire en sorte de détourner
l'objet de la manifestation lorsque l'on
est antiraciste c'est pour lutter contre
les phénomènes de haine lorsque l'on
lutte contre l'antisémitisme c'est pour
venir faire en sorte que les Juifs
puissent vivre comme tout le monde dans
la société quand on lutte contre le
racisme c'est pour faire en sorte que
ceux qui sont victimes de racisme
puissent vivre comme tout le monde dans
la société l'extrême droite elle ce
qu'elle fait c'est qu'elle utilise la
lutte contre telle ou telle forme de
haine pour rajouter une couche de haine
et bien il faut le dénoncer la l'extrême
droite non seulement un rapport c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire ambigu à
l'antisémitisme mais je tiens à dire par
rapport à toutes toutes toutes celles et
T ceux et je le vois souvent dans les
médias qui s'interrogent sur le fait de
de savoir si Marine Le Pen n son parti
est toujours antisémite comme celui du
père j'allais dire que il y a qume
quelques chose qui ne fait pas de doute
en général c'est que c'est un parti qui
s'attaque à l'égalité c'est un parti qui
joue sur le racisme c'est un parti qui
s'attaque à la République et il me
semble que lorsque il y a un parti
raciste fondamentalement et bien il n'a
pas sa place dans la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme et je prends souvent
cette image die donné a été condamné
pour antisémitisme il n'avait plus sa
place dans les manifestations contre le
racisme alors que je pense qu'il n'était
pas un raciste antinoir manifestement et
bien il faut aussi retrouver cette
cohérence dans la République et faire en
sorte et bien que chacun face au logique
de haine dise qu'il faut manifester
entre celles et ceux qui construisent la
République et non pas qui la détruis en
rajoutant sans cesse des couches de
haine voilà vous venez donc de suivre la
conférence de presse de l'ensemble de la
gauche avec Olivier fort pour le PS
marine Tondelier pour les éc iste et
Fabien Roussel pour les communistes
ainsi que le responsable des SOS Racisme
Pascal pereno vous avez entendu cette
cette prise de parole on voit bien que
l'ensemble de la gauche ne souhaite pas
et a tout fait pour ne pas être au côté
du rassemblement national pour qu'il y
ait un cordon républicain est-ce que le
RN a sa place à cette manifestation pour
vous mais tous les Français quel que
soit leur origine politique ou autres
ont place dans cette manifestation si
vous voulez ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que tous ces dirigeants de parti
disent on va sortir de la polémique et
il continuent à l'entretenir devant les
caméras il continuent à l'entretenir
hein et ils oublient l'origine de la
manifestation la manifestation VO
d'ailleurs à l'image la manifestation
n'a pas été prise son lesputés
rembltion parle que des partis c'est le
président de l'Assemblée nationale la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
le président du Sénat au nom de la
République française qui ont pris
l'initiative et ils sont intéressé non
pas au partis qui ne représente rien
hein 2 % des électeurs français adhèent
à des partis donc il ne représente pas
grand-chose ils devrait s'en rendre
compte ils sont adressés à la société
aux électeurs et vous n'allez pas
exclure des électeurs de LFI Doyez en
avoir vous n'allez pas exclure des
électeurs du RN voyez ça n'a aucun sens
on arriver on voit arriver la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale br pivé et on
voit Gérard Larcher le président du
Sénat qui commence à s'installer ils
sont au côté de Elsa Mondin Gava pour
une interview exclusive et tout de suite
et bien on les retrouve à l'instant
c'est à VOUS Elsa
oui bonjour madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale bonjour monsieur
le Président du Sénat tout d'abord merci
hein d'accorder cette interview
exclusive aux chaînes parlementaires
dans quelques instants vous allez
rejoindre le cortège de cette grande
marche civique que vous avez appelé de
vos vœux madame bronpivé vous avez sonné
la mobilisation générale pour quelle
raison parce que avec le président du
Sénat nous nous sommes dit que face à la
situation que notre pays connaît avec
cette montée des tensions cette montée
des actes antisémites cette montée de la
haine et des fractures nous ne pouvions
pas ne pas agir et que les fonctions que
nous exercions nous enjoignait de faire
quelque chose et de faire un acte fort
et c'est la raison raison pour laquelle
nous avons décidé ensemble de faire un
grand appel à une marche civique c'est
très important pour nous que cette
marche rassemble au maximum nos
concitoyens oui c'est une démarche
inédite Gérard Larcher cet appel
conjoint de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale et de vous-même président du
Sénat pour vous le moment l'imposer il
le fallait il faut un sursaut
républicain c'est ce que nous nous
sommes dit lundi tous deux dans le cadre
de rencontrre habituelle que nous avons
nous avions un ordre du jour mais le
vrai ordre du jour c'était la République
et notre ordre du jour aujourd'hui ce
dimanche c'est la République et la lutte
absolue contre l'antisémitisme qui est
le contraire des valeurs de la
République c'est donc un sursaut que
nous avons appelé et nous souhaitons que
ce sursaut ce soit un sursaut citoyen
est-ce que vous avez regretté certaines
polémiques mais il y en a eu notamment
sur la présence du rassemblement
national dans cette manifestation est-ce
que est que vous comprenez ceux qui se
sont interrogés ou ceux qui ont refusé
de venir à cause d'une telle présence
madame yelbron pivé vous savez notre
appel c'est un appel pour ce n'est pas
un appel contre et donc nous nous
appelons à marcher pour la République
pour les valeurs qui nous réussissent et
contre l'antisémitisme et donc nous
n'avons invité que les concitoyens nous
n'avons interdit évidemment personne de
manifester mais nous n'avons pas fait un
appel au partis politiqu nous aurions pu
le faire cont tenu des responsabilités
qui sont les nôtres ça n'a pas été notre
choix nous avons décidé de nous adresser
directement au peuple et pour nous les
polémiques ne sont pas à la hauteur ni à
la hauteur des enjeux qui sont comme
vient de le rappeler le président
Larcher c'est l'enjeu c'est la
République et donc les polémiques ne
doivent pas salir l'initiative inédite
que nous avons porortter et l'enjeu qui
est un enjeu qui nous dépasse tous mais
Gérard Larché l'Union nationale elle est
impossible aujourd'hui en France ben
nous allons le voir avec les citoyens
l'Union c'est peut-être les citoyens qui
vont la faire et j'ose espérer que ce
sont les citoyens je pense à ce qui va
se passer à Paris je pense à ce qui se
passe actuellement devant les
préfectures à l'appel des maires il y a
cette réaction de cette trame aussi des
500000 élus locaux qui disent ça peut
pas être comme ça dans la République
chaque citoyen doit être respecté pour
ce qu'il est quel que soit son origine
sa race ou sa croyance et c'est ça la
République et au fond nous sommes
vraiment les héritiers d'Aristide
brillant y compris sur l'aspect
religieux la loi doit protéger la foi
tant que la foi n'entend pas dicter la
loi et nous pensons que c'est la valeur
de la République c'est effectivement
extrêmement important de voir que notre
appel a été démultiplié sur tous les
territoires et moi j'ai eu beaucoup de
bonheur et j'ai du bonheur à voir ces
images des foules réunies à Nice à
Strasbourg à Valence parce qu'on voit
que c'est toute une nation qui répond à
notre appel et ça peut-être que c'est la
première bonne nouvelle de la journée
qu'il y en aura d'autres aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler d'un absent Emmanuel
Macron le chef de l'État ne sera pas
présent dans cette marche Gérard Larcher
est-ce que vous le regrettez écoutez
c'est sa décision
elle lui appartient j'ai compris qu'il
soutenait notre démarche et moi ce qui
compte aujourd'hui c'est vraiment ces
françaises et ces Français qui ont
besoin de se retrouver nous avons besoin
de nous retrouver sur des causes
essentielles et la République
l'antisémitisme ce sont deux causes
majeures et essentiel qui nous rassemble
même question à Madame BROUN pivé cette
absence du chef de l'État vous comprenez
ce choix alors le le chef de l'État
n'est pas absent il a écrit hier une
lettre au français euh pour justement
expliquer à quel point il tenait aux
valeurs de la République il tenait à ce
que cette marche soit une réussite et il
entendait cet appel donc que il en est
parfaitement solidaire il le salue il
est avec nous grâce à cette lettre en
pensée et en acte comme il l'a dit
chacun maintenant est à sa place et ce
qui est important c'est que nous nous
sommes à la nôtre à la tête de cette
manifestation madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur le
Président du Sénat merci infiniment de
nous avoir
accordéole que deux institutions avec
nos sensibilité différentes nous soit là
nous soyons aujourd'hui rassemblés
réunis c'est parce que pour nous la
République ça passe au-dessus de tout
c'est exactement mais nous avons c'est
ça a été noté dans la presse nous avons
des parcours politiques différents nous
avons nous appartenons à des familles
politiques différentes mais nous avons
effectivement cette république en
partage et je crois que c'est ça que nos
concitoyens attendent aujourd'hui des
hommes et des femmes politiques de ce
pays que nous sachions nous dépasser que
nous sachions dépasser ce qui peut être
constituer des clivages pour nous
rassembler autour de l'essentiel et
c'est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui et
bien merci infiniment d'avoir partager
cette interview sur les chaînes
parlementaires on va vous laisser
rejoindre la tête de cortège et on
suivra évidemment sur les chaînes
parlementaires cette marche contre
l'antisémitiste merci merci beaucoup
merci Elsa moningava interview exclusive
donc de yel brun Pivet et Gérard Larché
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
et du Sénat qui ont à nouveau lancé un
appel pour la République pour défendre
les valeurs républicaines face à la
recrudescence des actes antisémites un
appel pour les citoyens et pas au partis
politiques Jonathan Ayoun vous avez
entendu bien évidemment cette prise de
parole cette marche citoyenne euh tout
le monde a le droit de s'y rendre pour
vous ou est-ce que vous êtes gêné par la
présence du rassemblement
national la rue n'appartient à personne
que des électeurs du rassemblement
national décident de s'engager contre
l'antisémitisme on va pas le critiquer
que le parti lui-même joue et se mette
en scène dans une action contre
l'antisémitisme ça il y a quelque chose
d'indécent d'indécent parce que vous
regrettez la présence du Rassemblement
National de France regrette leur
présence et je regrette le fait que ce
soit les premiers à avoir répondu à
l'appel il faut savoir
s'effacer CIT alors Marine Le Pen
n'urait pas d être la première d'abord
des personnalités de la société civile
d'abord des artistes surtout que 3 jours
avant le président de ce parti avait dit
que Jean-Marie Le Pen n'était pas
antisémite c'est-à-dire que c'est par
pensait pas que Jean-Marie Le Pen était
antisémite donc c'est un parti qui a du
mal même à nommer l'antisémitisme à le
dénoncer lorsqu'il vient une forme de
négationnisme chez eux il ils in
l'antisémitisme alors ça enfin je
rappelle que quand même alors il est pas
député d'une des deux chambres de
l'Assemblée ou ou du Sénat mais c'est un
député du Parlement européen
Jean-François JAL qui est un député RN a
tenu des propos négationnistes et
péténistes et Jordan bardellaa a démarré
en étant son assistant parlementaire
tout ça on ne peut pas l'effacer mais ce
qui est le plus dérangeant c'est quand
il y a une instrumentalisation de la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme pour
dénoncer l'antisémitisme d'ailleurs on
va pas se plaindre que le RN dénonce
l'antisémitisme qui vient
am mais il faudrait qu'il le dans un
même temp en parlant desur et ils ne le
font pas tis que l'on voit Sébastien
Chenu le député rassemblement national
qui vient de de s'exprimer effectivement
dans le cortège du rassemblement
national qui va commencer à partir Émile
Isabel qui votre réaction à à cela
effectivement au rassemblement national
qui a été le premier à s'exprimer qui
achève un peu plus encore son processus
de normalisation dans ce qu'il essaie de
donner comme message en tout cas sur oui
on a l'impression que c'est l'ultime
étape pour vraiment cette
institutionnalisation cette
normalisation mais moi je vais vous dire
je je suis assez contente finalement
parce que là on arrive à en parler de la
xénophobie du côté antisémite de ce
parti alors et donc d'extrême droite
parce que j'avais l'impression que
c'était c'était plus dans la rhtorique
voilà on a on avait plus le droit ou on
on on ne parlait plus du rassemblement
national comme ça donc tout d'un coup
c'est vrai avec les maladresses de
Jordan Bardella qui a remis à jour ce
pass qui est toujours là qui est
toujours très présent même s'il est
beaucoup plus atténué et d'ailleurs
Zemour leur a servi beaucoup là-dessus
mais je suis contente parce que ben
voilà ça y est on reparle de xénophobie
d'antisémitisme pour parler de de
l'appel commun il me semble que là les
termes sont plus clair moi j'ai lu
l'appel commun qui a été publié c'était
moins précis c'était beaucoup en rapport
avec l'attaque terroriste évidemment du
Hamas c'était la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme pas sur le racisme plus
globalement qui aurait permis d'intégrer
un petit peu tout les luttes et donc les
uns et les autres de manifester et pas
seulement pour les Juifs et au côté des
Juifs il me semble que c'est un petit
peu plus clair l'appel citoyen on
l'entend un peu plus alors que c'était
quand même une connotation un petit peu
plus politique auparavant donc merci de
de leur donner la parole et de pouvoir
expliquer çateindre aussi les polémiques
dans domage que ça intervienne tard et
qu'il se soit pas rendu compte des
maladresses de cet appel après sur l'arc
républicain je trouve que là et là je
parlerai du gouvernement il y a encore
beaucoup de confusion beaucoup de de de
choses à clarifier parce qu'on a entendu
un jour ellisabeth borne dire que le
rassemblement national et à la fille ne
faisait pas partie de la républicain et
un autre jour Emmanuel Macron qui
conviait et l'un et l'autre aux
rencontres de Saint-Denis et résultat
comme pour cet événement qui en sortait
le grand vainqueur un Jordan Bardella
somptueux qui avant la réunion et après
la réunion commentait tout ce qui s'est
passé alors que les autres partis
politique étit beaucoup moins apparent
moi il me semble qu'on faut qu'on fasse
attention à ça il faut que le
gouvernement soit clair là-dessus quand
qui va chercher un peu à droite et un
peu un petit peu plus à droite au Sénat
ou à l'Assemblée pour faire passer ses
lois attention il y a des il y a des
conséquences très néfaste à ça il y a
des dommages collatéraux encore une fois
l'aide médicale d'État qui part c'est
pas anodin même si j'espère que ça va
être reformaté et reformulé à
l'Assemblée nationale mais attention à
ces glissements attention ça ça fait que
bénéficier au rassemblement national et
ça donne quelque chose de pas très clair
au niveau du gouvernement Judith Cohen
Solal vous trouvez effectivement qu'à
des fins électorales e chacun on appelle
soit au rassemblement national soit pas
en fonction de l'Arque républicain je
pense que c'est défs électoraliste mais
peut-être pas que ça et je trouve par
exemple que le mot polémique me parî oui
Marine Le Pen sur ces images vous la
voyez première image de Marine Le Pen
arrivant à la manifestation donc en que
de cortège voilà elle vient descendre de
la voiture avec son garde du corps et
elle vient donc à cette à cette
manifestation rejoindreun quarantaine de
députés du rassemblement national qui
ont prévu de de marcher de la place des
Invalides jusqu'au jusqu'au Sénat je
vous ai coupé
oui je disais que le mot polémique me
paraît peut-être pas tout à fait juste
parce que il y a il y a un problème on
pourrait dire qu' que ce sont des
problématiques qui ont été soulevées et
finalement je suis d'accord avec vous il
fallait bien qu'elle le soit parce que
il y a comme une manière de de Marine Le
Pen s'exprime on va Marine Le Pen qui me
coupe la parole ça SEV audessus de
l'événement et s'il continue à faire de
la petite politique politicienne encore
une fois ça en dit plus long sur eux que
sur nous au vu du passé de votre parti
vous ne comprenez pas que la
présence que l'histoire de notre
mouvement au contraire a démontré
que notamment sous ma présidente capable
de
[Musique]
faire des choix
absolument par d'ambiguité ce matin an
par
ex
ça vous fait rire en plus ça vous fait
sourire ça vous fait sourire vous
devriez avoir honte je vais vous dire de
sourire de ça vous devriez
avoir effectivement on va revenir sur
cette polémique mais je je dis qu'en
effet on a du mal à entendre ce qu'elle
dit parce qu'elle dit que l'histoire de
son parti s'inscririt hors de de des
affaires antisémites des questions
antisémites vous voulez Rapp le
contraire que les racines du
rassemblement national c'est le National
son ce sont des des vafen donc comme le
rappelé tout à l'heure
Rousseau qui qui sont à l'origine de la
création de ce parti pierre Bousquet
avec Jean-Marie Le Pen je je on rappelle
quand même que continuellement ils n'ont
cessé de euh alors de nourrir des
questions non pas des polémiques mais de
l'antisémitisme des propos antisémites
que Jean-Marie Le Pen a été condamné
mais aussi quand ils ont changé le nom
donc il y a pas si longtemps de Front
national en rassemblement national ils
ont gardé la flamme rassemblement
national avait déjà été utilisé à un
moment donné par Jean-Marie Le Pen
lui-même mais euh à part ça Marine Le
Pen a déclaré dans le Congrès où elle a
changé ce nom que elle ne reniait en
rien toute l'histoire du parti tout ce
qu'avait fait al effectivement alors
elle a dit qu'elle prenait tout à ce
moment-là c'était en 2011 et en 2015
Pascal Perino elle a exclu son père
Jean-Marie Le Pen du Front national
c'est devenu le rassemblement national
est-ce que le rassemblement national est
tout à fait le Front national pour vous
le rassemblement national est différent
du Front national bien sûr qu'il y a des
éléments de continuité mais quand vous
regardez l'histoire des partis aucun
parti n'est fixe dans une essence
éternelle le Parti communiste a beaucoup
changé qui viendrait à l'idée de
d'interpeller monsieur Roussel en le
traitant de leader d'un parti stalinien
personne donc le rassemblement national
a connu oui une évolution cette
évolution elle est symptomatique le
président du Front national a été
condamné par la justice voyez quittons
le débat politique à plusieurs prise
pour antisémitisme donc là en effet il
devait bien y avoir jusqu'à la tête du
parti de l'antisémitisme dans le Front
national la présidente actuelle n'a
jamais été condamnée pour antisémitisme
mais elle assume hein elle dit assumer
parti pass une partie du passé et le
président du Ren dit que Jean-Marie Le
Pen pensait-il n'était pas antisém faut
pas voyez il faut pas sélectionner ce
qui arrange en terme d'événement il est
vrai que elle a exclu son père à la
suite d'une saillie antisémite de son
père en 2015 elle l'a exclu du parti ce
qui montre sa volonté alors on a parlé
de
dédiaboliser et cetera mais c'est vrai
que cet élément a certainement participé
à l'insertion du rassemblement national
dans le système politique français et
fait qu'aujourd'hui et bien oui toutême
faut pas oublier ça c'est le premierre
élector français c'estàdire que si vous
voulez quand vous parlez à des électeurs
français faut bien vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui à peu près et bien un sur
TR s'apprête à voter pour Marine Le Pen
mais est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il y a
un antisémitisme caché et là chez une
partie des français ou pas a
l'antisémitisme partout il est plus
important en effet dans les extrêmes
particulièrement à l'extrême droite et à
l'extrême gauche mais il y a
l'antisémitisme absolument
part puis notamment l'quête annuel du du
rapport du CNCDH la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme
rappelle l'état des préjugés en France
chaque année et on voit bien qu'ils sont
à l'extrême droite encore très vivace
plus de plus de la moitié enfin près de
40 % disent que les Juifs on un rapport
particulier à l'argent ou plus de 30
qu'ils ont trop de pouvoir on voit que
c'est encore très très vivacee et très
présent d'abord à l'extrême droite aussi
à l'extrême gauche mais d'abord à
l'extrême
droite et que il y a malgré tout cette
stratégie qui en effet marche et des
évolutions de la part du RN de vouloir
se démarquer du saut infamant
d'antisémitisme et la mise en scène et
l'exclusion véritable en 2015 n'a pas
empêché que pendant les mois et les
années qui ont suivi le parti était
encore financé par une un micro parti
dirigé par Jean-Marie Le Pen donc la
rupture pouvait aussi être interprété
comme de façades encore aujourd'hui Jud
dit rappelé 2011 mais 2022 c'était les
50 ans du parti elle a encore rappelé
donc il y a encore moins d'un an elle a
rappelé qu'elle ne rejette rien de
l'histoire de ce parti et non seulement
elle ne rejette rien mais elle s'inscrit
en réalité aussi dans une stratégie qui
était déjà celle de son père et que nous
avons oublié celle de vouloir dire
qu'ils sont contre l'antisémitisme et de
vouloir montrer qu'il y a un
antisémitisme ailleurs que chez eux en
1990 lors justement de la dernière
grande marche contre l'antisémitisme
après la profination du cimetière de
Carpentra Jean-Marie Le Pen a tenté de
participer à cette marche pas à Paris
mais à Carpentra il en a été empêché
donc on voit bien qu' y a quand même
quelque chose de répétitif dans la
stratégie allez tout de suite pardon
Émilie on va vous redonner la parole
mais on va tout de suite se rendre à
nouveau dans la manifestation rejoindre
notre journaliste Quentin Calmet qui se
trouve non loin des responsables de
gauche Quentin comment se passe la
manifestation
oui j'ai quitté les responsables de
gauche je je me trouve au tout début du
cortège qui est prêt à s'élancer on voit
les premiers les premiers manifestants
qui sont juste ici sur et bien le K
d'orsé juste à l'ongle avec l'Assemblée
nationale et on voit tout là-bas les
responsables les principaux responsables
qui vont ouvrir la marche et qui sont
derrière de ce côtéci et juste un mot
très important pour les manifestants et
bien il ne pleut plus ce qui donc permet
et bien d'être tous ici peut-être plus
nombreux avec voilà assez peu de de
pancartte mais parmi celles que on voit
et bien on a vu amis juifs on vous aime
par exemple donc le le cortège qui est
prêt à sélancer d'une seconde à l'autre
pour rejoindre tout d'abord l'Assemblée
nationale puis le boulevard
Saint-Germain puis le boulevard
Saint-Michel arrivé au Sénat mercici
qutin calm donc en direct de la
manifestation qui va partir dans 5
minutes maintenant cette marche donc
pour la République et contre
l'antisémitisme prévu pour démarrer à
15h devant l'Assemblée nationale
direction donc le Sénat et où une partie
en tout cas du cortège de tête est déjà
présent Émilie zapalski vous pouvez
poursuivre votre propos sur la présence
du rassemblement je voulais revenir sur
voilà le positionnement du front du
rassemblement national qui essaie en
effet de de limiter euh ses visés
antisémites ou en tout cas de nettoyer
ça bon on a vu que Marine Le Pen bon
même si on entendait pas vraiment ce
qu'elle disait ça avait l'air un peu
nébuleux mais euh le glissement il est
il est sur le racisme euh aujourd'hui
évidemment c'est une c'est la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme mais si on
parlait de racisme globalement au
rassemblement national on passe d'une
cause à une autre ou en tout cas d'un
contre à un contre autre du contre juif
au contre musulman et quelque part euh
c'est c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
pas plus toléré mais en tout cas qui va
plus dans le sens de l'histoire il me
semble qui va dans le sens de d'une
partie de la société qui trouve qu'au
niveau de la sécurité qui a beaucoup de
de préjugés sur le lien qui a d'ailleurs
été fait par le gouvernement entre la
sécurité et l'immigration et quand on
parle d'immigration là on parle plutôt
d'immigration musulmane donc quelque
quel en quelque sorte le rassemblement
national surf là-dessus et et comme l'a
dit Pascal ça fonctionne parce que un
Français sur trois est preneur quel
quelque part de ça et d'ailleurs je
crois qu'il y a eu un sondage glissement
global à Dr de la
soci de la typologie du racisme et le
Ren surf un peu là-dessus et on voit que
7 Français sur 10 aujourd'hui était
plutôt convaincu que le RN avait sa
place dans la manifestation oui mais
alors moi j'irais plus loin dans dans
dans la poursuite je crois que les
Français ils sont pas dupes quand on a
eu un Éric Zemour qui entre parenthèses
défile là alors que lui aussi comme
Jean-Marie Le Pen il a été condamné pour
des propos racistes alors pas envers des
Juifs mais envers des musulmans et comme
par hasard on accepte sa voilà sa
présence là donc voilà c'est c'est la
géométrie variable mais si on va plus
loin Éric Zemmour a parlé du Grand
remplacement là quand il était pas
candidat il a fait rêver tout le monde
fantasmé en disant on va être r il a
surtout réhabilité Pétin
aussi mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
ça n'a pas duré d'accord il a fait 8 9 %
ce qui était assez exceptionnel pour un
candidat qui était pas connu en tout cas
que connu en tant que journaliste et
tribin des médias de ces news mais les
Français ils achètent pas ça et Marine
Le Pen elle s'en est dépétrée parce
queelle s'est branchée sur le pouvoir
d'achat et elle a essayé de cacher
justement ce côté à la fois antisémite
et contre les musulmans parce que Éric
Zemour était là pour en parler mais
c'est bien présent et à mon avis dès
qu'elle sort du bois et qu'elle parle
d'autrees choses que du pouvoir d'achat
où là elle a pas énormément de
possibilités ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est que le le soutien à ce genre
de thèse ça fait pas long feu et on le
voit bien au niveau de la loi
immigration qui est en train de discuter
les fr ils veulent un équilibre entre
les deux Solal votre réaction aussi et
ça reprend un peu ce que vous disiez à
ce ce sondage qui dit que donc 69 % des
Français soutiennent la marche cont
l'antisémitisme et 59 % attention à à
cette phrase mais pense que les
personnalités de gauche et de la
majorité présidentielle ont tort de ne
pas participer à une manifestation au
côté du rassemblement national donc si
on traduit ça veut dire que une majorité
de Français pensent qu'il faut marcher
manifester aujourd'hui avec le
rassemblement national votre réaction à
ce que pensent effectivement les
Français d'abord je voudrais juste vous
dire quelque chose parce qu'on est là
sur les questions tout à l'heure
antisémite avant antisémite qu'est-ce
que c'est alors juste je me pr une
petite blague juive qu'est-ce qu' un
antisémite c'est quelqu'un qui n'aime
pas les Juifs plus qu'il ne faut et je
pense que là il y a je pense qu'il y a
c'est-à-dire que il y a quelque chose à
un moment donné il va y avoir un éveil
de quelque chose qui est latend et donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe comment est-ce
que gère Mar Le Pen cette affaire là
comment elle espère elle maintenir au
sein de ses troupes des une majorité de
gens enfin au moins 40 % qui qui sont
antisémites ENF qui se décare comme tel
qui ont tous les préjugés antisémites
elle ne lutte pas à l'intérieur de son
parti du tout contre cela et donc et et
par ailleurs en effet elle a une
opération de communication qui est
formidable parce qu' elle arrive quand
même à dire que non là elle vient de
dire on l'entendait très mal mais que
sont partis en en l'occurrence n'a
jamais été antisémite elle l'oire de
notre mouvement a démontré que alors
donc il y a il y a quand même quelques
gens on voit bien qu'il y a du dénis de
la mauvaise foi donc que ça marche parce
que c'est ça ce que ce que
dit le sondage dit ah s'il y a des
bonnes
volontés bon
volontés la marche pour la République
est contre l'antisémitisme va partir de
l'Esplanade des Invalides on va
retrouver Quentin Calmet qui se trouve
sur place Quentin vous êtes plutôt dans
le cortège de tête à côté d'un citoyen
qui est venu marcher cet
après-midi voilà il s'appelle é
effectivement il a tenu être présent
nous sommes effectivement tout devant à
l'avant du cortège qui va s'élancer d'un
instant à l'autre première question
toute simple Eric pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez tenu à être présent en ce
dimanche bah j'ai tenu à être présent
pour bah participer à à comment
diraisje une comment dirait à une
expression de de d'égalité ici en France
et de voilà de pas mélanger tous les
tous les problèmes que il y a des choses
qui se passent à l'extérieur mais que
ici on est en France et tout le monde a
le droit d'avoir sa religion quoi voilà
et qu'on comprenne bien vous êtes pas
membre d'une association particulier
vous êtes pas concerné d'une façon
particulière c'est vraiment c'était
logique pour vous au-delà de de tout ce
qui se passe oui tout à fait oui j'ai
aucune aucune appartenance politique ni
associatif ni rien du tout quoi
important d'être là pour vous oui c'est
important pour moi pour participer à cet
effort de liberté ici en France quoi et
donc voilà merci toutes les les
polémiques politiciennes tout ça ça ne
vous a pas du tout pas pas du tout pas
du tout bien merci merci beaucoup pour
ce témoignage ici à l'avant du cortège
qui est prêt à s' lancer d'un instant à
l'autre merci merci beaucoup Quentin V
tê voilà une intervention qui remet
l'église au milieu du village Pascal
Perino on voit tandis que pardon on voit
aussi et bien des images qui montrent
des des des images les affiches des
schau fourés avec des personnes qui
disent à Marine Le Pen de ne pas venir
participer
à cette marche contre
l'antisémitisme ne veulent pas de toi
voilà ce que cri et bien c'estes
manifestant qui s'opposent à la présence
de Marine Le Pen au sein de cette marche
citoyenne bon voyez deux images qui dit
la politique n'a pas grand chose
exactement on n pas grand chose à faire
avec ma présence ici et d'autre part et
bien on le voit quand même cette
polémique reprend le dessus sur une
autre partie de la marche PASC en tout
cas il faut faire une remarque d'après
les images on verra ensuite il semble
qu'il y ait du monde hein et ça c'est
important parce que la question de la
mobilisation tout le monde était dans le
flou hein avant que cette mobilisation
commence c'est quoi une mobilisation
réussie pour vous mobilisation réussie
c'est une
mobilisation qui
atteindrait la plus de 100000
participants si vous voulez la dernière
fois c'était on était allé même jusqu'à
200000 participants lors de la
manifestation de
1990 euh à la suite de l'affaire de
Carpentra hein donc làprès on a vu qu'il
y avait des mobilisations qui étaient
moins fortes pour Ilan Alimi ou pour mir
on était autour de 30000 donc là vous
vous dites peut-être que 100000 ce
100000 serait certainement certainement
à succès deuxième remarque ce citoyens
que l'on vient enfin de voir montre que
parmi les dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont là et bien c'est
avant tout des gens comme ce citoyen
hein et que les militant finalement à
politique au-dessus de la politique ou
c'estjet mettant leur orientation
politique au fond de leur poche avec un
mouchoir pardessus il manifestent en
effet pour défendre les valeur de la
République et pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme voilà c'est des choses
simples mais fondamentales qui
permettent le vivre ensemble dans la
République française et et le reste
j'allais dire ce ne sont que des
militants qui continuent à entretenir la
chikaya lamentable à laquelle on a
assisté depuis 10 jours cette union
finalement nationale on peut la
retrouver chez de simples citoyens qui
sont venus comme Éric manifester oui
c'est c'est c'est eux qu'il faut mettre
de communion d' heureux les voir de les
voir à l'image de les voir à l'image
parce que c'est d'ailleurs eux qui vont
faire le succès de la marche c'est pas
la mobilisation des politiques c'est
l'appel de l'assemblée du Sénat et après
la mobilisation des citoyens qu'il faut
mettre en avant et non pas à la fois la
venue des députés la venue des
représentants de l'État qui quelque part
de leur propre initiative devrait
s'effacer plus et c'est peut-être ça
qu'il y a qui dérange c'est leur
indessence à ne pas s'effacer après moi
j'ajouterai un petit mot tout de même
sur sur alors un mot sur ces images que
nous voyons en direct imag donc nous
voyons il el brune Pivet et Gérard
Larcher qui vont donc rejoindre la tête
de cortège de cette marche aujourd'hui
marche civique pour la République il se
trouve actuellement devant les colonade
de l'Assemblée nationale côté donc
kedorset au tout début du boulevard
Saint-Germain pour une sorte de de photo
qui va réunir toute la la tête de
cortège devrait se trouver sur cette
photo Nicolas Sarkozy François Hollande
un certain nombre de de ministres vous
apercevez Olivier du sopte le ministre
du Travail quelques 25 ministres he on
président leur présence à cette
manifestation Jean-Louis Debray Jonathan
arfy aussi qui se trouve là donc pour le
Conseil représentant des des Juifs de
France Jean-Marc h l'ancien Premier
ministre socialiste de François Hollande
d'ailleurs les deux anciens présidents
de la République François Hollande et
Nicolas Sarkozi devraient également
participer à à cette photo
de phipcien Premier ministre qui se
trouve également sur
ces relation avec le Parlement Bruno Le
Maire et Roland lescur on voit également
Roland lescur et Bruno Le Maire voilà
une partie du gouvernement 25 ministres
sont attendus au sein
du TR sur sur ces images bien sûr au
côté de Gérard Larcher de de François
Hollande il y a elbrun Pivet qui
s'entretient avec la première ministre
quelques minutes avant le début de cette
marche Bernard casn et manuel Vals qui
sont également présents sur cette cette
photo donc rassemblement pour pour la
République cor le grand Rabin de France
également présent donc plusieurs
représentants des des cultes qui se
trouvent aussi à cette à cette marche
Jonathan Jonathan ah voilà Nicolas SAR
aussi qui est là franis Hollande
également qui est présent également
l'ancien président socialiste du Sénat
Jean-Pierre Bell au 2è rang derrière
Jard Larcher Jonathan Aoun c'est un
symbole fort de voir toutes ces
personnalités sur ces personnalités
politiques de premier plan d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui toutes ces personnalités
des institutions juives ensemble sur ses
marches devant l'Assemblée dans
l'histoire des Juifs de France c'est
quand même quelque chose chose de très
important parce qu'il veut tout de même
rappeler que dans la longue histoire de
la présence des Juifs en France c'est à
l'Assemblée en
1791 que pour la première fois ils ont
été regardé comme les autres que pour la
première fois ils sont devenus citoyens
c'est pas en 1789 au moment de la
déclarationemblée vote la pleine
citoyenneté pour les Juifs donc cette
image là au regard de l'histoire elle a
de la force avec cette banderole avec un
message évidemment très fort pour la
République et contre antisémitisme
toutes ces ces personnalités politiques
qui se sont réunies et des cultes pour
dire non à ces actes antisémites qui se
multiplie sur le territoire français
depuis le 7 octobre dernier ilyisapelski
ouais moi je trouve que c'est très fort
c'est vrai qu'on parle des citoyens
parce que c'est eux qui vont faire la
manifestation et c'est eux qui passent
un petit peu au-dessus des polémiques et
des problèmes et et tant mieux mais
c'est vrai que c'est fort de voir ces
représentants Unis moi je trouve qu'il y
a un petit manque il y en a un qui
manque voilà je prés République mine de
rien les symboles et ces images là elles
sont très fortes et même si demain ou ce
soir on se dit 200000 ou je sais pas
combien et ça marquera le coup c'est
vrai que d'avoir ses représentants et
franchement on le ressent il y a quelque
chose de l'ordre de l'émotion et de et
de de la cohésion d'une unité qui
dépasse un petit peu l'éclivage et ça
c'est important je trouve de Solal quand
vous voyez cette photo ces images vous
vous dites que peut-être que cette
marche est déjà réussie quand on voit ce
rassemblement alors d'abord moi je
voudrais dire que je suis ému en fait
oui c'est émouvant je trouve que c'est
émouvant et il est vrai que on se dit
qu'Emmanuel Macron aurait pu choisir par
exemple d'être juste là peut-être de ne
pas aller à la marche mais de trouver
une forme de de de présence malgré tout
et là il aurait été dans cette photo je
pense que ça n'aurait pas euh il y a eu
quand même cette lettre aux Français qui
a été largement commentée qui a été
publié dans la presse pour vous ce n'est
pas un engagement assez fort du
président de la République je je pense
que ce n'est pas une question
d'engagement personnel ou d'engagement
il y a là euh cette idée voyez nous
voyons cette image et nous sommes ici
j'ai l'impression sur ce plateau un peu
tous émus et il manque donc voilà mais
mais je ne pense pas que ça veut dire
qu'il s'engage pas Pascal Perino votre
on voit la la foule qui est rassemblée
après avoir vu et bien tous les
responsables politiques responsablebl
aussi des institutions juives euh qui
étaient également euh rassemblé euh ces
deux images font écho aussi Pascal pin
bien sûr bien sûr parce que ces hommes
et ces femmes que l'on voit sur les
marches de l'Assemblée nationale sont
les représentants de la nation hein ce
sont des hommes et des femmes qui ont
été élus par ce peuple que l'on voit sur
le qu d'orset et qui maintenant va
entamer la manifestation sur le
boulevard Saint-Germain puis le
boulevard Saint-Michel pour rejoindre le
Sénat donc là vous savez on parle très
souvent de crise de la représentation en
disant la représentation politique est
éloignée du peuple là on a une une image
forte où la représentation politique est
au côté du peuple et on ne peut que s'en
réjouir on voit effectivement ces images
très poignante hein de nos responsables
politiques réunis donc devant
l'Assemblée nationale et puis on le
redit hein c'est une initiative
totalement inédite de Gérard Larcher et
de yel brun Pivet d'appeler à un
rassemblement pour la République et
contre l'antisémitisme émiliseapski
cette cette foule que l'on voit là
évidemment il faudra voir les chiffres
il faudra voir si cette mobilisation est
si importante qu'elle qu'elle peut le
montrer sur sur ses images mais c'est
déjà le signe qu'il y a un réveil
républicain oui oui on sent qu'il a
qu'il y a du monde et probablement
j'espère qu'on aura des chiffres
importants mais pour revenir sur cette
émotion qu'on ressent moi je me souviens
pour la manifestation de Charlie abdo
qui avait cette idée ou là là j'y vais
quand même c'est inquiétant moi je me
souviens de m' poser la question même
pour mes enfants est-ce que c'est
vraiment sérieux de de d'aller avec eux
manifester bon c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose parce que évidemment c'est
pas la même situation forcément mais je
trouve que ces images elles sont fortes
aussi pour ça de voir les différents
responsables politiques avec les les
problèmes de sécurité et je trouve que
c'est ça qui marque c'est que contevant
et Maré qu' au-delà des clivages et
au-delà de la sécurité parce qu'on
entend aussi cette excuse he pour le
président que c'est pour des raisons de
sécurité voilà c'est assez fort je
trouve d'y aller malgré tout on y va et
ça ça on le ressent on voit cette image
donc plutôt d'union mais on a vu tout à
l'heure et bien des images d'chaufouré
notamment du côté de la
de la marche du rassemblement national
on va d'ailleurs rejoindre Stéphanie des
piierres pour revenir sur ce que nous
avons vu tout à l'heure Stéphanie
qu'est-ce qui s'est exactement
passé alors il s'est passé queun
collectif qui s'appelle le golem qui se
réclame comme un collectif de juif de
gauche a essayé de bloquer l'arrivée
l'entrée de Marine Le Pen et des élus
sur l'esplanade des Invalides alors ils
étaient quelques dizaines avec des
affiches et il criaiit casse-toi Le Pen
les Juifs on te veut pas finalement ils
ont été bloqués par par les forces de
l'ordre le le cortège de Marine Le Pen a
légèrement fait un virage sur la droite
pour pouvoir continuer son parcours et
là vous le voyez les élus et Marine Le
Pen sont dans cette dans ce groupe
derrière moi ils sont à peu près au
milieu de cette esplanade des invalis
donc il y a marine Le Pen Jordane
bardellaa et des dizaines de députés
rassemblement
national des pierres donc pour toutes
ces ces précisions vous êtes donc à côté
des membres du rassemblement national
présents à cette marche cont contre
l'antisémitisme Pascal Perino quand vous
voyez C ces bouleversements ces
échaufourés qui a pu y avoir est-ce que
vous êtes finalement étonné c'est pas la
première fois que la présence de Marine
Le Pen à des manifestations contre
l'antisémitisme sont perturbé sûr bien
sûr depuis j'allais dire 40 ans
presqueun demi-sècle on est habitué on
est habitué à cela et le cortège
s'élance he là Pascal Perino sur ces
image ce sont des images beaucoup plus
rassurantes d'un pas assez assez assuré
et assez rapide hein avec des gens qui
se hissent là à la hauteur de
l'événement et non pas ceux qui
cherchent à le faire rétrograder
oui on voit donc la première ministre
ellisabeth borne qui est au milieu avec
Gérard Larcher Yael brun pivé Nicolas
Sarkozi François Hollande Jonathan harfy
on voit Laurent Fabius me
semble-t-il voilà donc là on se trouve
tout tout juste devant devant
l'Assemblée nationale direction donc le
boulevard saint Germain voilà le le
trajet que va emprunter cette cette
marche pour rejoindre donc le Sénat ces
deux institutions donc de de la
République qui se sont manifestées
ensemble de façon totalement inédite oui
il a du sens aussi ce trajet Pascal
Perino et les deux institutions qui
veulent se rejoindre on passe pas par la
place de la République on passe pas par
les passages habituels des d'utres
manifestations la place de la Nation
c'est une première c'est une première en
effet une manifestation en effet qui
fait le lien entre les deux
assemblées représentatives qui incarnent
euh la République française l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat le peuple et les
territoires il y a là quelque chose de
symboliquement très for les
représentants du peuple finalement qui
se trouve mobilisé avec une volonté de
ne pas mettre les chefs de partis pour
ne pas trop politiser les manifestation
même malgré la polémique qu'oné l'esprit
originel du texte qui était comme l'ont
rappelé d'ailleurs les deux présidents
présidentes de l'Assemblée et du Sénat
qui était un appel en effet aux citoyens
il s'agit d'une marche
citoyenne est derrière des calicos de
parti Jonathan Ayoun Emmanuel Macron a
dit s'en prendre aux Juifs c'est
atteindre la République vous avez
l'impression que là la République répond
présent à cette à cet appel pour
soutenir les Juifs de France oui en
étant ensemble dans cette marche en les
voyant ensemble personnalité politique
représentant de la nation et
représentant des institutions juives de
France marcher ensemble il y a quelque
chose de fort qui nous dit bah nous ne
faisons qu'un de toute façon la
République est une et indivisible et un
citoyen juif lorsqu'il est pris pour
cible en tant que juif c'est également
la France qui est touché parce que en
France le racisme l'antisémitisme ne
sont pas autorisés c'est aussi important
de le rappeler c'est depuis 1972
particulièrement que cela est constitué
aujourd'hui comme un délit donc voir
cela c'est quelque chose d'important le
dire c'était ça l'était également et
bien sûr que les messages parce que on
faisait référence tout à l'heure à
quelqu'un qui
disait amis juifs on vous aime ça fait
plaisir mais c'est pas un message
d'amour qu'on attend aujourd'hui c'est
un message politique qui vient dire
l'antisémitisme n'a pas sa place en
France et ce ne concerne pas que les
Juifs et donc en effet lorsqu'il dit
quand on s'attaque à un juif c'est on
s'attaque à la France ça vient rappeler
que ce n'est pas que l'affaire des Juifs
oui il y a quelque chose de peut-être
aussi dans le contexte d'aujourd'hui on
entend certaines personnalités qui
craignent aujourd'hui la montée d'un
antisémitisme dit acceptable est-ce que
vous vous vous le craignez aussi voilà
quand dis l'antisémitisme d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas celui d'hier il est il est
plus acceptable est-ce que vous le voyez
monter ça déjà parce que l'antisémitisme
étant donné qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
délit il avance plus masqué il est
difficile à déceler à identifier et donc
à combattre et la deuxième raison c'est
parce que avec le temps étant donné que
là on retourne on revient
particulièrement depuis les années 2000
un antisémitisme violent voire parfois
même meurtrier et bien ça peut aussi
laisser passer plein d'autres formes
d'antisémitisme qui sont plus dans le
discours on vient dire bah ce n'est pas
si grave puisque d'autres en sont la
cible physiquement laissons passer cela
et en réalité la véritable lutte contre
l'antisémitisme c'est de rien laisser
passer et surtout d'identifier toutes
les formes de préjugés qui sont à
l'œuvre et malheureusement les enquêtes
d'opinion ne cessent de nous montrer que
au moins 20 % des Français adhèrent à
des préjugés antisémites donc il y a un
gros travail à faire Solal vous avez vu
Macron qui Emmanuel Macron qui dit vous
notez la résurgence d'un antisémitisme
débridé c'est ça finalement c'est
qu'aujourd'hui cet antisémitisme il est
plus acceptable comme le disait Tam
aussi il est il est plus diffus dans la
société il est il il avance masqué
puisque en effet comme c'est un c'est un
délit donc on peut pas on peut pas se
dire personne ne se dit antisémite et à
la fois donc sont multiplié des
expressions verbales des expressions
après qui amènent jusqu'à des choses
physiques enfin quand on peint des des
étoiles de David sur les murs ou qu'on
met des croix gamé sur les murs donc il
y a comme une forme de libération de
certaines ce qu'on appelle tout d'un
coup des expressions aue au lieu que ça
soit défini comme des actes antisémites
donc on dit bon bah ça va il a juste
fait ça je pense aussi que il y a une
une manière face à l'inquiétude que cela
représente de vouloir aussi parfois
minimiser les actes en disant bon ça va
ça va c'est que ça bon c'est que une
croam c'est que
des des gosses qui crient dans le métro
alors que justement on essae et je pense
que des membres notamment de la de la
communauté juive ont eux aussi tendance
à vouloir il y a il y a des deux
réactions mais il y a aussi cette
réaction de vouloir dire bon ça va parce
que si chaque chose là est grave ce qui
est le cas et du coup ça devient quand
même très inquiétant quel est donc
l'avenir des Juifs en France parce que
beaucoup de Juifs se posent la question
pas quex je pense s'en vont parce que on
entend qu'il y a beaucoup de de Juifs
qui qui enlèv ce signe qui est devant la
porte sont retournés voà y a il y a des
gens qui qui disent qu'ils donnent plus
leur nom s'ils ont des noms des
patronymes qui sont trop identifiés donc
il y a une inquiétude une peur qui est
en train de s'installer et donc face à
ça il y a parfois une tendance à
minimiser à essayer un peu de réduire la
portée de des expressions antisémites on
va retrouver Quentin mais à présent qui
se trouve dans cette marche pour la
République et contre l'antisémitisme
Quentin vous êtes à côté d'un d'un
citoyen qui marche on va retrouver
Quentin dans un tout petit instant alors
que vous voyez sur ces images et bien le
le carré de tête qui s'est élancé avec
toutes les les personnalités politiques
y AEL brun Pivet Gérard Larché Elisabeth
borne que vous avez pu voir en gros plan
au côté de de François Hollande sur sur
ces ces imagesal périno l'une des
questions qu'on peut se poser face et
bien on dis à cette présence de
l'antisémitisme qui demeure et qui
avance peut-être caché c'est comment
lutter contre l'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui comment
enseigner sans doute et bien la deuxème
guerre mondiale quelle place ça doit
avoir aujourd'hui dans nos programmes
scolaires et et peut-être même aussi
ailleurs non on sait bien sûr que le
terrain de l'éducation que ce soit
l'éducation familiale ou l'éducation
national est un des terrains essentiels
pour faire en sorte en effet que les
enfants puis les adolescents ne véhicule
pas beaucoup de stéréotypes
d'exclusion vis-à-vis des juifs ou
vis-à-vis d'autres d'autres minorités
cela ne suffit pas toujours parce que
aussi l'antisémitisme comme d'autres
formes de racisme connaît des mutations
il faut bien voir que l'antisémitisme
dans les décennies qui ont suivi
l'après-gerre était un antisémitisme où
le souvenir de la Choa était extrêmement
présent oui avec le temps le
renouvellement des génération la Choa
s'éloigne et donc d'une certaine manière
un espace se crée pour qu'il y ait des
phénomènes de résurgence de
l'antisémitisme deuxième élément l'antis
il faut entenir la mémoire de la Choa
auprès des jeunes notamment vous savez
que tous les enseignants le disent dans
certains établissements il est difficile
d'enseigner aujourd'hui la choix et là
l'antisémitisme a changé aussi il faut
le dire bien sûr que vous avez toujours
un
antisémitisme d'origine catholique très
fort une exme dro réactionnaire mais
vous avez aussi un antisémitisme qui est
porté par heureusement par une minorité
de la population française musulmane qui
vé on va revenir he bien évidemment sur
ces multi formes d'antisémithisme on va
retrouver Stéphanie des pierres à
présent qui se trouve dans la
manifestation Stéphanie vous êtes à côté
d'un citoyen qui est venu marcher cet
après-midi oui un Français de confession
juive donc vous êtes aujourd'hui à cette
manifestation dites-nous pourquoi et ben
pour ma solidarité vis-à-vis de tous les
antisémites et il faudrait que la la
solidarité contre l'antisémitisme
l'antisémitisme et il faudrait que il y
ait beaucoup de Français qui ne soient
pas seulement de confessions juives qui
soient dans cette manifestation c'est ce
que nous allons voir et c'est ce que
nous allons observer pour savoir si
toute la communauté française est
concernée par ce problème vous avez
applaudi tout à l'heure le cortège de
Marine Le Pen et Jordane Bardella
pourquoi ben moi j'ai fait comme eux
j'ai changé d'avis j'étais anti Front
national il y a une quinzaine d'années
une dizaine d'années mais en analysant
la situation on se rend compte que il y
a une importance aujourd'hui de prendre
conscience du problème de
l'ismanalisation de l'ismalisation qui s
qui devient un un gros problème pour
toutes les sociétés occidentales merci
merci merci beaucoup Stéphanie des Pierr
pour ce duplex qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire voilà cette prise de par ils
étaient contre les Juifs maintenant ils
sont contre les musulmans c'est enfin
c'est c'est un peu ce qu'on entend dire
et c'est ça le positionnement parce que
au-delà même de Le Pen on entend Marion
maréchal qui fait ce lien aussi he qui
dit les Juifs on les protège parce que
on se bat contre l'islamisation citoyen
de confession juif doncon voit aussi que
du coup la Barère sent mieux protégé
aujourd'hui par le rassemblement
national que par tout aut parti poli
c'est un glissement du racisme au sein
du rassemblement national et encore
c'est pire que ça puisque comme vous
dites il y a quand même encore des
relants d'antisémitisme au sein du
rassemblement national mais il mettent
une couche surtout de racisme contre les
musulmans parce que quelque part ça va
fonctionner et ça fonctionne encore
comme ça est que Reet musulmanans fait
le soutien au Ju c'est ce que disait
Emmanuel Macron fin ça c'est que
simplement c'est l'expression du citoyen
estce que les Ju ne se trompe pas
finalement de de soutien mais mais c'est
c'est c'est la la mécanique du
rassemblement national qui est à l'œuvre
c'est simplement ça
l'efficité évidemment que ça montre
l'efficacité et je dirais après sur sur
la question du plus globalement du
racisme parce que moi moi je je dirais
racisme parce que on voit évidemment que
toutes les questions d' choix pour des
enfants d'aujourd'hui c'est très
compliqué des plus les plus jeunes et
plus ça ira moi on a d'anciens pour
parler de ça évidemment moi on a de
mémoire il y a l'histoire de de du
collège là ou du gymnase anne- Franck
qui a été renommé parce que ça disait
plus rien aux enfants c'est terrible
mais c'est la réalité aussi il faut
apprendre l'histoire peut-être autrement
et moi j'ai l'impression que l'histoire
elle se répète souvent et qu'on a besoin
d'un coupable et là c'est c'est
exactement ce qui se passe on avait des
coupables vraiment choisi par l'histoire
et on en choisit d'autres l'histoire
elle est comme ça on a des crises on a
des difficultés qu'elle soit financière
sanitaire ou quoi on a besoin d'avoir
des coupables de tout leur mettre sur le
dos ce que fait le rassemblement
national et il le fait avec
l'immigration maintenant plutôt
musulmane on a le reflet de ça et ça
c'est terrible parce que avoir des gens
qui sont en plus de confessions juifes
qui sont dans la manifestation avec ces
idées là on revient au début de notre
discussion c'est-à-dire pourquoi je suis
là est-ce que c'est pour défendre les
Juifs mais est-ce que c'est aussi pour
combattre une forme
d'immigrationpire finalement cette prise
de parole Jonathan
elle inspire quelque chose qui
s'installe dans la communauté juive et
chez beaucoup de juifs depuis longtemps
c'est-à-dire un niveau d'inquiétude
tellement important qu'ils se sont dans
une fébrilité tellement grande qu'ils ne
savent même plus à quel sens se vouer et
qui pourrait les protéger et ce qui
amène certains à pouvoir se laisser
tenter se laisser bercer par un champ
des sirènes de celui qui a la parole la
plus forte ou entre guillemets la plus
magique qui peut jouer aussi sur les
haine de fait être juif ça vaccine pas
de la bêtise et pas du racisme donc il y
en a beaucoup qui se laissent porter par
Cees discours de haine mais il a y a
aussi il faut l'entendre la volonté
d'avoir une parole politique forte et
que quelque part et ça on revient au
début de de notre discussion la présence
du président de la République aussi
transmet ce message là et donc oui que
certains se laissent tenter par la
parole de l'extrême droite c'est pas
nouveau dans l'histoire des Juifs tout
courts il y a des Juifs qui se laissent
sentés par les extrêmes surtout quand
ils viennent leur dresser un champ des
sirènes aussi puissant parce que là le
on l' dit elle a été la première à
s'exprimer mardi et depuis et bien
plusieurs semaines dit que le
rassemblement na
est une protection est un rempart
aujourd'hui contre l'antisémite elle se
présente comme un bouclier elle ne cesse
de le faire et d'avoir parfois même des
mots justes parce que par exemple après
le 7 octobre c'est la première av
utiliser le terme de pogrome donc les
Juifs sont sensibles à ces
m l'Assemblée nationale mais il faut
entendre ce qu'il y a de
stratégiquement pervers dans sa démarche
et de cynique c'est que il ne faut pas
être dupe elle elle le fait non pas pour
rassurer enfin il me semble c'est quoi
c'est du calcul politique du calcul
politique c'est vouloir un certificat de
respectabilité qui ne pourrait donné que
par la question d'être clair enfin sur
l'antisémitisme et quelque part ça agite
aussi une notutre forme de préjugé les
Juifs et le pouvoir parce que ils le
disent lui al lui-même l'avait dit c'est
le dernier verrou à faire sauter pour
qu'on atteigne le pouvoir comme si les
Juifs étaient donc un obstacle ou un
moyen d'avoir le pouvoir et quelque part
ça réagit des formes de préjugés il ne
faut pas en est dupe également lorsqu'on
analyse ces discours là mais j'entends
et moi je suis pas là pour diaboliser ou
condamner ces Français de confession
juifs qui sont tellement dans la peur
qu'ils peuvent même parfois se mettre à
à agir de cette manière là mais selon
moi c'est très instantané c'està-dire
c'est dans les moments où il y a des
montées d'antisémitisme dès que ça va
redescendre ils vont revenir entre
guillemets à la raison et quelque part
ils ne sont pas dupes mais là ils ont
besoin de s'exprimer de cette manière-là
je suis le premier à le déplorer Judit
CEN soal et puis Pascal Perino je je
pense que en effet la peur est est
vraiment à l'œuvre je pense que en fait
ça ne coûte pas très cher on va dire à
Marine Le Pen d'avoir le discours
qu'elle a ce sont des paroles
rassurantes et puis ça fait plusieurs
années qu'elle cherche à faire cela
qu'elle cherche à séduire les Juifs de
France parce qu'en effet elle est
convaincue que tant qu'il y aura la
marque antisémite sur son parti elle ne
pourra pas
atteindre les les hautes instances
qu'elle voudrait atteindre pour elle
c'est une marque et en effet Louis alio
mais elle arrive à le retirer le le
scotch là manifestement alors elle
arrive vraiment hein elle arrive pas
vraiment parce que ça heureusement on
constate quand même que de nombreux les
représentants de la communauté juive se
sont exprimés eux en contre de cela
c'estàd il qui regrettait la
présencetion donc de nombreuses
institutions juifes qui sont représenté
par le CRIF il y a aussi le Consistoire
il y a aussi ce qu'on a vu ici on voit
le Fond Social Juif unifi enfin
énormément de de de d'institutions
juives qui eux euh qui ell Contin
continuent à entendre qu'il y a
certainement un danger dans ce champ des
sirènes tant qu'il n'y a pas de choses
beaucoup plus profondes que des discours
certainement bien menés enfin d'ailleurs
elle a même pas besoin dans de mener de
longs discours elle a des réactions elle
a certains mots clés et ça marche et ça
parle aux Juifs de France aussi bah ça
parle ça parle je dirais à la peur à
l'inquiétude et à l'angoisse des Juifs
est-ce que ça constitue un plafond vert
fin avoir le sens des nuances hein euh
quand on écoute ce citoyen juif il
dénonce quoi il dénonce pas la
population musulmane il dénonce
il
t at-il le tort de dénoncer l'islamisme
bien
l'islam ENF il voulait dire l'islamisme
c'est bien l'islamisme qui a tué le 7
octobre c'est bien l'islamisme qui a tué
Dominique Bernard à race donc je veux
dire il faut tout même pas si vous est
transformer la la dénonciation de
l'islamisme comme étant le vecteur d'une
violence terroriste comme étant une
marque
d'islamophobierictement rien à
voir qu' a dit ou alors moi j'ai mal
entendu mais il a parlé d'islamisation
de la société ce qui est pas tout à fait
pareil juste un commentaire parce qu'on
se le faisait comme ça entre nous faut
remettre les choses à leur place on a
marine Le Pen qui est quand même coincé
et qui doit partir très à droite dans le
cortège parce que elle est poursuivie
parce que il y a des Juifs qui lui
disent de gauche qui lui disent qu'on
veut pas d'elle et elle est dans un
petit endroit avec une dizaine de
représentants on a quand même cette
belle banderole avec des représentants
de partis politiques et d'anciens
présidents qui sont là je pense qu'il
faut aussi le mentionner et pas inverser
l'histoire comme Marine Le penut pas que
la polémique prenne le pas sur l'Union
que l'on voit quand même s'afficher au
sein de cette on lui fait une bonne
place elle fait sa stratégie de
communication c'est très réussi au point
même que Pascal entend des choses
différent de ce que le citoyen a dit
mais il faut faire attention à ne pas
lui donner autant d'importance c'est
bien et clair de voir juste dans son jeu
et de ne pas être dupe par rapport à son
jeu cynique et ses approches parce que
comme vous l'avez dit elle porte en
elle-même dans cette démarche des
préjugés sur les Juifs le dernier verou
pour pour avoir le pouvoir il faut voir
aussi comment cet appel commun du
président de l'Assemblée de la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
du président du Saintin font échola et
donneent cette importance c'est quand
même assez beau ces images il faut pas
qu'on l'oublie il faut pas qu'on inverse
les les les proportions je trouve alors
effectivement il y a il y a cette
présence du rassemblement national qui
est très commenté très décriée même par
par certains il y a aussi l'absence de
la France insoumise Jonathan Ayun est-ce
que le problème il vient de la présence
du Ren ou de l'absence de la France
insoumis qu'est-ce qui vous choque le
plus s'il fallait non choisir je P il ne
faut surtout pas hiérarchiser ni entre
les fautes politiqu de l'un ni entre les
calculs politiques de l'autre comme il
ne faut pas hiérarchiser entre toutes
les formes d'antisémitisme quand elle s
là LFI oui en tout cas c'est une faute
extrêmement grave c'est un moment
historique dans l'histoire de la gauche
française qui est en train de se
dérouler sous nos yeux sur la question
des juifs comme ça l'a déjà été dans la
grande Histoire de la gauche française
sur la question de l'antisémitisme
notamment au moment de l'affaire de
réfus et il faut être capable de pouvoir
le dire fortement le comportement de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et des instances
dirigeantes de la France insoumise n'est
n'est non seulement pas à la hauteur de
l'événement mais là pour le coup et même
une
faute porte une responsabilité très
grande sur la question de la sécurité
des Juifs en France puisqu'ils agitent
des formes d'antisémitisme jean-mie Jean
Jean voyez j'allais faire le l' jean-l
Mélenchon prierf merci merci à tous les
les d'être venu participer cette
émission spéciale évidemment continue
tout au long de cette marche pour la
République et contre l'antisémitisme à
suiv bien évidemment en direct sur LCP
on va retrouver à présent els mondava
qui se trouve
dans le cortège au côté des Moon
oui qui garde un peu d'humour parce
qu'il guide les photographes pour éviter
que tout le monde tombe c'est un moment
sérieux monsieur issoun pour vous
c'était important d'être présent
aujourd'hui apparemment c'est pas
sérieux il y a des gens qui font des
selfies avec moi euh oui c'est un moment
sérieux mais on peut on peut avoir le
sourire quand même surtout quand on voit
qu'il y a autant de monde donc c'est
génial justement c'est vrai que c'est
difficile quand on est dans une
manifestation de s'apercevoir mais là
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de monde ça vous rassure ouais c'est
très rassurant franchement puis je vois
pas je vois pas que des Juifs vous êtes
pas juif monsieur bah voilà donc c'est
parfait non non donc c'est très bien
c'est chouite qu'il ait pas que des
Juifs il fallait que ce ne soit pas que
la communauté juive qui soit en soutien
mais tous les Français mais oui oui tous
les Français enfin la plupart des
Français je sais pas combien on est mais
je pense qu'on est beaucoup et ça c'est
chouette ça ça me réchauffe le cœur il y
a eu des polémique politique alors je
sais pas si vous les avez suivi monsieur
soun mais qu'avez-vous pensé de ceux qui
disaient oui mais je m' este mais pas
forcément à côté du RN qui voulait je
trouve ça idiot je trouve ça
complètement idiot le RN ils font ce
qu'ils veulent c'est un bon prétexte
pour pas défiler en fait je pense donc
ouais c'est pas terrible vous êtes une
personnalité connue reconnue c'est ant
on a vu plusieurs personnalités du monde
du spectacle c'est important comme moi
oui oui c'est chouette parce que pour
certaines personnes en toute modestie on
représente peut-être quelque chose donc
peut-être que notre voix peut porter
donc honnêtement jeis pas si ça va
changer grand-chose au racisme ambiant à
l'antisémitisme ambiant mais c'est mieux
que rien merci beaucoup
C mooun merci de nous avoir accorder
cette interview merci beaucoup
elamondingava qui était donc en tête de
cortège et qui était avec
IE soun et tout de suite on va également
rejoindre un autre journaliste qui est
avec nous Quentin Calmet Quentin et vous
vous trouvez et bien avec une une
citoyenne avec un drapeau bleu blanc
rouge qui également participe à cette
marche contre
l'antisémitisme tout à fait Tam nous
sommes au niveau de l'Assemblée
nationale effectivement ce petit groupe
qui a choisi de manifester avec le
drapau bleu blanc rouge bonjour Kitri un
mot sur la raison la raison qui fait que
vous êtes ici avec votre groupe d'amis
ben on avait envie d'être uni sur ce
sujet que qui nous interpelle beaucoup
et être unis pour la paix et montrer que
voilà on pouvait être nombreux à être là
aujourd'hui et de marcher ensemble
est-ce qu'il y a eu un momentù vous avez
hésité à venir ici aujourd'hui à Paris
pour manifester alors j'habite Paris
donc c'était facile pour moi de venir en
revanche j'avais des petits doutes en
terme de sécurité j'avais un petit peu
peur de l'effet de foule euh mais
j'étais assez rassuré par tout ce que
j'ai entendu et puis par le fait qu'on y
aille ensemble aussi donc c'est pour ça
que j'y suis venu aujourd'hui oui tout
se passe très bien à l'heure où l'on se
parle il y a pas mal de monde hein qui
passe autour de nous on a la sensation
en tout cas de d'une mobilisation forte
de là où on se trouve un dernier mot
avec vous qui triste si vous le voulez
bien mais on entend des débats
politiques entre partis qui sont là ou
qui sont pas là qu'est-ce que ça vous
évoque vous mais je je je pense que ça
n'a pas de sens ici en fait voilà on est
là pour la paix on est là pour les
hommes et les femmes et je pense que la
politique n'a pas sa place dans ce débat
là merci Kitri rafhaella un mot avec
vous maintenant approchez-vous s'il vous
plaît qu'est-ce que vous vouliez ajouter
à ce que vient de dire votre ami
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait que par exemple
les politiques fassent en plus on est
très touché de cette mobilisation
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai qu'on attend
désormais des actions concrètes des
politique pour sécuriser les lieux de
culte et pas seulement et permettre
d'empêcher tout autre ement antisémite
est-ce que lorsque vous voyez ce monde
autour de nous qui défile à priori une
foule assez assez importante qu'est-ce
que ça vous avoque puisqu'on savait pas
quelle serait la mobilisation
aujourd'hui je suis très touchée que
voir que cette population est très
éclectique on peut voir des personnes on
sent de de toute horizon de toute
nationalité et toute religion j'avais
également des doutes de survenir avec
mes enfants et je suis ravie qu'il
puissent participer à ce moment
historique on l'espère merci rafhael
merci Kitri voilà un petit peu pour des
personnes qui manifestent comme vous et
moi Mo des des citoyens dans dans le
cortège merci Quentin Calmet pour tous
ces témoignages de citoyens venus
participer à cette marche pour la
République est contre l'antisémitisme
vous le voyez sur ces images cette
marche qui est partie aux alentours de
15h15 de l'Assemblée nationale boulevard
Saint-Germain et qui avance qui
progresse en direction du Sénat ou à
l'initiative de la présidente de
l'Assemblée yelbrun Pivet et de Gérard
Larcher président du Sénat nous
poursuivons donc cette émion i spéciale
sur LCP avec nos invités et nous
accueillons Florent Vadillo bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
polthologue et président de
l'éérie et
puis Galina Elbaz bonjour vous êtes
vice-présidente de la Licra et avocate
merci d'être avec nous également avec
nous Anne Sophie Seban bonjour bonjour
vous êtes directrice de l'Américan
Jewish commite Paris docteur en
géopolitique Anne Sophie seulement on a
entendu et bien les prises de parole de
ces citoyens qui craignaient pour leur
sécurité dans cette marche mais qui
finalement sont rassurés ce que l'on
entend à travers ca aussi c'est et bien
le fait qu'il réclame aussi des des des
actes au-delà du symbole et bien pour
rassurer un peu plus bien la communauté
juive face à la recrudence la
recrudescence des actes antisémites oui
exactement est-ce qu'on ce qu'on voit là
aujourd'hui c'est une mobilisation très
forte et face au phénomène qu'on voit
depuis un mois c'est-à-dire plus de 1000
actes antisémites en moins d'un mois
c'est une déferlante antisémite c'est TR
fois plus que sur une année entière en
202 que sur une année entière et c'est
si on se place du point de vue des
Français juifs une expérience
extrêmement douloureuse extrêmement
inquiétante et cette mobilisation elle
permet de dire que la France fait bloc
que la France a conscience de ce
phénomène et nous on le voit dans les
dans les sondages qu'on publie tous les
2 ans une grande majorité des Français a
conscience que ce phénomène est
important à conscience qu'il concerne la
société dans son ensemble et c'est cette
démonstration que j'espère qu'on on
verra dans les rues avec un une
mobilisation massive et aussi l'envie de
dire qu'effectivement les larmes ne
suffisent plus les larmes de crocodiles
face aux victimes juives d'antisémitisme
ne suffisent plus il faut maintenant
agir de manière beaucoup plus forte et
être à la hauteur mettre les moyens qui
seront à la hauteur du phénomène qui
frappe une partie de no conso qu'est-ce
que vous demandez des moyens beaucoup
plus forts mis dans l'éducation enfin je
veux dire si on considère que ce
phénomène il est une menace pour la
démocratie si on a conscience que quand
on commence par la haine des Juifs c'est
c'est c'est nos valeurs RPU et c'est
l'avenir de notre pays qui est en jeu il
faut que les moyens mis en œuvre par
l'État soient à la hauteur et et gagnent
tous les secteurs en matière de
formation en matière d'éducation en
matière de sécurité il y a un engagement
qui est très fort mais c'est un combat
de long terme et et il faut y mettre des
moyens financiers supplémentaire pour
commencer alors on nous a rejoint
également sur ce plateau Marc Nobel
bonjour vous êtes historien et essayiste
merci d'être avec nous cet après-midi
pour cette émission spéciale vous le
voyez sur ces images à droite et bien le
cortège qui s'est élancé avec les
présidents des deux assemblées et un
certain nombre de personnalités
politiques comme François Hollande
ellisabeth borne ou encore Nicolas
Sarkozi et puis sur la gauche de votre
image et bien il y a le cortège du
rassemblement national qui se trouve
plutôt en queue de cette mobilisation un
petit peu plus loin du côté des
Invalides et qui a décidé donc de
manifester de se mobiliser également
contre l'antisémitisme on a vu que quand
Marine Le Pen était arrivé à cette
marche et bien il y a eu quelques
quelques débordements Marine Le Pen a
dit nous sommes exactement là où nous
devons être Florent vadidio est-ce que
vous voulez bien commenter cette cette
phrase de Marine Le Pen je pense qu'elle
est l'aboutissement d'une stratégie
politique qui est gagnante gagnante à
tout point de vue et et et la
manifestation elle est très importante
elle envoie un message très clair de
mobilisation et je pense qu'il faudra
retenir ce message mais on pourra pas
oublier un autre message politique qui
est que pour la première fois alors on
entend la Marseillaise pardonnez-moi je
vous coupe mais on entend la
marseillaise qui est
[Musique]
chanté au
bataillons
marchons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marchons
moment historique là Florent vaadio
qu'on est en train de vivre ici il y a
évidemment un moment d'union nationale
qui nous fait penser aux grandes
manifestations qui avaient eu lieu après
le Bataclan par exemple et donc je pense
que c'est très important de garder ce
message là mais il y a un autre message
politique il ne faut pas oublier c'est
que pour la première fois le
rassemblement national participe à une
manifestation républicaine qui vient en
quelque sorte permettre ce qu'on appelle
un mécanisme de lustration alors on
avait déjà vu Marine Le Pen à la marche
pour m knnol elle s'était rendue à ce
cette mobilisation on les a vu à la
marche organisée par le CRIF aussi bien
sûr il y a il y a effectivement
plusieurs manifestations auxquelles le
Front national le rassemblé national a
participé on est là dans une
manifestation où tous les partis
politiques sont représentés tous les
partis politiques républicains on a eu
pendant ce cette dernière mandature un
grand débat pour savoir qui appartenait
ou pas à l'arc républicain clairement le
rassemblement national par la stratégie
qui est la sienne la participation à ses
pressionent de manifestation mais avec
une forme de d'apothéose dans cette
manifestation à s réin ve que là Marine
Le Pen appartient à l'arc républicain
parce qu'elle se
trouves a tous les attribut reste à
savoir maintenant s en a le programme et
je pense qu'il reste une ambiguïé de ce
point de vue- là vous dites tous les
partis républicains mais la France
insoumise ne se trouve pas représenté ça
veut dire quoi que Marine Le Pen entre
dans l'arc républicain au moment où
Jean-Luc Mélenchon en sort ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il y a une stratégie
sécessionniste de la part de la France
insoumise à l'égard de des autres partis
politiques une volonté de distinction
qui a été clairement mise en scène et
qui n'est plus le cas de celle de Marine
Le Pen on va continuer à suivre cette
marche citoyenne contre l'antisémitisme
avec Quentin Quentin Calmet on voit
cette foule Quentin et on voit de très
nombreux C cyen au-delà de cette image
des politiques que l'on a vu tout à
l'heure de très nombreux citoyens qui se
sont rassemblés à Paris cet
après-midi tout à fait Tam je me trouve
toujours devant l'Assemblée nationale
c'est-à-dire bien à l'angle du K d'orset
et vous le voyez sur ces images de
Cédric Delbar on voit cette foule et
bien dont on dont on ne perçoit pas à
l'horizon la fin du cortège
effectivement de nombreux français avec
des drapeaux bleu blanc rouge des
applaudissements régulièrement dans la
foule et donc effectivement cette marche
avec du monde de là où l'on se poste
d'ici de ce point de vue depuis
l'Assemblée nationale du monde et une
foule jusque au bout de notre
perspective Tam merci beaucoup Quentin
Galina elle base ce que l'on voit à
travers cette image on a entendu et bien
d'une part la Marseillaise quand même
qui a retenti c'était quand même une
image chargée d'émotion on voit
maintenant cette foule de de citoyens
c'est que et bien c cette marche elle
n'est pas que politique elle est avant
tout citoyenne c'est-à-dire
l'antisémitisme et et l'affaire de tous
est-ce que vous avez l'impression et
bien qu'on qu'on y arrive avec ces
images euh oui je je tiens à dire que
voir à l'écran cette fou c'est
extrêmement émouvant la Marseillaise
chanté je crois que pour les les membres
actifs hein des associations
antiracistes dont je fais partie hein je
président de la c'est un message qui va
qui nous va droit au cœur et qui est en
concordance avec les études d'opinion
que l'on constate depuis de nombreuses
années les Français font de la question
de l'antisémitisme l'affaire de tous
Anne Sophie Seban l'a rappelé je tiens à
dire que le baromètre qui est publié
chaque année par la CNCDH indique qu'à
peu près entre 50 à 70 % des Français
considèrent que la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme est nécessaire dans
notre pays ils sont au rendez-vous de
l'histoire mais ce qui est aussi
hisorique c'est que les Français ont
refusé qu'on les prive de ce moment dans
leur intégralité il y a pas que des
Français juifs aujourd'hui et c'est très
émouvant de ce point de vue-là parce que
les Français juifs ont été seuls depuis
15 ans à manifester face à la résurgence
absolument épouvantable de
l'antisémitisme dans notre pays qui a
créé des morts alors c'est vrai qu' faut
rappeler les chiffres quand même
multipliés par 3 depuis le 7 octobre
plus de 1250 acte antisémite Marc Nobel
comment vous expliquez-vous cette cette
recrue des ence des des actes
antisémites est-ce que vous la Liez
directement au conflit
israëlo-palestinien ou est-ce que c'est
un antisémitisme caché qui s'est qui
s'est
libéré vous savez nous disposons de
chiffres qui sont très clairs ce sont
les chiffres des actes antisémites
depuis le milieu des années
90 pour vous donner un ordre d'idée en
1998 et
1999 respectivement 81 et 82 actes
avaient été comptabilisés et dès le tout
début du mois d'octobre
on assiste à une explosion d'une très
grande violence entre les mois d'octobre
novembre décembre et pour l'année de000
nous comptabilisons
744 actes antisémites c'est-à-dire 10
fois plus que vous liez à quel phénomène
à la répercussion du conflit
israëlo-palestinien à chaque conflit
israëlo-palestinien se multip les actes
terit et à une hystérisation de
l'antisémitisme à des violences
antisémites qui sont commises à 3500 km
maêtre des lieux où se déroule ce
conflit et qui prennent pour victime des
Français de confession juifes qui n'ont
rien demandé ce que je veux dire c'est
que depuis 2000 jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc
depuis 23 ans les Français juifs sont en
souffrance et un peu partout dans le
monde aujourd'hui les antisémites se
donnent le droit de haïr les Juifs parce
qu'ils haïssent Israël et ils procèdent
donc de facto un amalgame qui est
intolérable et quand je vous dis partout
c'est aussi bien en Australie où les
Juifs sont en souffrance qu'au Canada
aux États-Unis où il y a des violences
qui sont commises à l'heure actuelle et
des manifestations d'une très grande
violence en Allemagne et France des
Juifs des acteurs antisémites ils
existaient avant 48 aussi il y a cette
histoire aussi il y a vous savez
l'antis'est pas lié à l'état d'Israël
l'antisémitisme est une maladie qui quel
que soit l'époque quel que soient les
raisons quel que soit le moment quel que
soit l'actualité va va se réveiller va
va s'actualiser va se mettre en marche
pour le simple fait que des gens veulent
tuer les Juifs en fait pensez à ce que
l'on a vu moi je je voudrais quand même
dire ici penser à ce que l'on a vu sur
les murs de nos villes ces dernières
semaines les morts au Juifs qu'on a vu
et l'inscription qui a été écrite sur
les murs d'une école de Strasbourg où il
y avait marqué un bon juif est un juif
mort et à côté vive la Palestine vous
voyez à quel genre d'individu on a
affaire voilà h Anne Sophie Seban euh
c'est un peu paradoxal parce que on voit
ces études d'opinion qui disent bien non
les Français ne sont pas antisémites
mais vous le disiez en même temps on
voit et bien cette montée de de de des
actes antisémites voilà x 3 donc
antisémite ou pas antisémite alors et où
se trouve l'antisémitisme en France
aujourd'hui bien sûr alors
l'antisémitisme effectivement les
Français sont mobilisés ont conscience
que c'est un problème mais en revanche
quand on regarde la la la la porosité
des préjugés antisémites au sein de la
société française ils existent toujours
nos études le montrent également sur les
préjugés classiques les Juifs ont trop
de pouvoir dans les médias ont trop de
pouvoir dans la finance c'est à chaque
fois 1/4 un/ers des Français qui
continuent de partager ce type de
préjugés c'est pr cette porosité est
plus prégnante chez les militants de de
du rassemblement national de la France
insoumise et on note aussi une prénance
beaucoup plus importante chez les
Français de confession et de culture
musulmane maintenant quand on a dit ça
j'aimerais revenir sur cette notion
aussi de d'importation du conflit euh
parce que moi il me semble qu'il faut
dire quelque chose ce qui s'est passé
dans les années 2000 c'est moins une
importation du conflit en tant que tel
qu'une importation d'une propagande et
de messages de groupes propalestiniens
radicaux qui ont instilé qui ont réussi
à faire infuser ici en France à travers
des groupes islamistes à travers
d'autres groupes l'idée que la création
d'Israël était une entreprise coloniale
racise en véhiculant des narratifs faux
qui ont permis qu'on s'entraîne ici à
des Juifs c'est une guerre de
l'information c'est une propagande
effectivement qui a permis aussi de
normaliser certains groupes comme le
ramas aujourd'hui on voit dans cette
dernière étude qu'on a quand même 5 %
des Français qui soutiennent le le ramas
on a eu ce phénomène qui a permis de
faire de ces groupes de terroristes des
résistants et là il y a des
responsabilités aussi politiques on le
sait certaines franges notamment à
l'extrême gauche on les sait faire soit
par clientélisme et je crois que c'est
leur donné aussi trop trop trop de
d'excuses que parler que de clientélisme
soit par idéologie ont laissaé prospérer
euh cette propagande qui a permis qu'on
en qu'on s'en prenne directement aux
Juifs mais c'est moins le conflit qu'on
a importé que cette propagande il me
semble que cette idéologie qui fait
qu'on s'en est pris aux Juifs sur notre
sol alors
15h50 le cortège s'était lancé depuis un
peu moins d'une heure maintenant il
progresse lentement boulevard
Saint-Germain pour rejoindre le le Sénat
avec ces personnalités politiques que
vous voyez à l'antenne et puis sur votre
GO gauche à l'écran et bien il y a un
certain nombre de Français qui sont
venus pour manifester qui se trouvent
eux encore devant l'Assemblée nationale
et qui progresse donc lentement et qui
marche donc pour la République et contre
l'antisémitisme Elsa vous vous
trouvez-vous dans cette manifestation
dans cette mobilisation est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup de Français comme on peut le
voir sur les image
oui écoutez Brigitte il y a beaucoup de
monde on est au croisement de la rue
Saint-Thomas d'quin et du boulevard
Saint-Germain je vous explique comment
ça se déroule vous avez vu surement sur
les images le cortège de tête il y a
plusieurs pauses ensuite nous marchons
ensuite nous nous posons quelques
instants il y a des des gens qui sont
parfois dans les dans les fenêtres des
immeubles qui saluent la foule la foule
les salut c'est ce qu'on voit à
l'instant là c'est une famille avec des
jeunes enfants qui saluent la foule la
foule elle est assez silencieuse là où
je me trouve on entend pas forcément de
slogans mais toutes les 5 10 minutes on
entend des salves d'applaudissements des
applaudissements aussi des gens qui sont
coincés dans les rues alentour qui
encourageent les manifestants donc je me
trouve quoi à quelques dizaines du
mètres du cortège de tête et j'imagine
qu'il y a encore beaucoup beaucoup de
gens derrière nous une marche dans le
calme où ici il y a des anonymes des
personnalités ou encore des élus et on
avance tout doucement en faisant des
pauses de temps en temps des
applaudissements et c'est vrai qu'on
entend pas beaucoup de slangançis c'est
étonnant dans les manifestations là ici
les gens sont sont dans le calme
s'applaudissent et marchent tout
doucement dans l'objectif de rejoindre
évidemment le Sénat merci
merciamava Florent vadilot votre
commentaire sur cette image vous a parlé
tout à l'heure et bien de l'union
politique impossible mais l'union de la
société française est-elle possible
est-ce que c'est ce que l'on voit à
l'œeuvre aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
se méfier des jugements durables au-delà
d'éléments qui sont effectivement très
très symbolique ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il y a un élan d'adhésion à un
discours contre la haine il y a eu une
vague d'émotion très forte à partir du 7
octobre et on est dans cette
répercussion dans une forme de de
communion contre la violence qui vient
fracturer la société et qui pose de plus
en plus de questions on le voit puisque
cette recrudescence elle inquiète
l'ensemble du territoire il y a pas une
une cristallisation dans quelques
parties du territoire il y a vraiment
une propagation qui est inquiétante
après il faut retenir que c'est un petit
parcours de manifestation donc je pense
que les organisateurs ont eu une la
volonté de de ne pas être soumis à une
faible affluence et qu'ils sont
clairement débordés par une très forte
affluence ce qui est heureux ce qui est
bon signe et donc je pense que ça fera
partie encore une fois d'un rituel
républicain qui s'est installé il y aura
des dates déjà longs comme ça la marche
après le Bataclan celle-ci très
importante parce que P que déjà ça
s'inscrit dans le cadre de ces marches
historiques que l'on va retenir qui ont
réussi à mobiliser vraiment largement
les Français indéniablement avant le
plateau on échangeait toutous sur nos
expériences pour rejoindre l'Assemblée
nationale et Toulouse disait que partout
où nous étions c'était saturé il y avait
beaucoup de monde il y avait beaucoup
d'affluence donc clairement il y a une
forme de volonté d'union de communion
dans cette forme de marche sur un
message qui ne peut-être on ne peut plus
rassembleur c'estàdire qu'effectivement
c'est la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
maintenant il faut aussi voir quelle est
la composition de ces manifestations et
là où il n'y a pas de manifestation il
faudra se poser des questions sur là où
il y a eu beaucoup d'affluence et là où
il n'y a eu pas de manifestation alors
on va repartir dans ce cège et cette
cette marche contre l'antisémitisme Elam
monangava vous êtes au côté de Bertrand
Pancher c'est le président du groupe lot
à l'Assemblée nationale
oui Bertrand Pancher vous vous êtes pas
posé la question une seconde pour vous
c'était important d'être là aujourd'hui
non c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
important contre les tous les actes
antisémites pour la
République et évidemment contre toute
forme de racisme je suis là pour
représenter le group Liot et je suis là
aussi pour soutenir les grandes valeurs
de notre pays
l'égalité liberté l'égalité surtout la
fraternité c'est vraiment important pour
moi d'être ici aujourd'hui alors la
fraternité c'est toujours difficile de
se rendre compte de l'affluence est-ce
que pour vous voilà il y a beaucoup de
monde est-ce que ça vous rassure de voir
B boulevard Saint-Germain noir de monde
oui ça me rassure beaucoup ça me rassure
beaucoup je crois que les les Françaises
et et les Français comprennent vraiment
la
situation je crois que personne ne veut
se faire entraîner contre ces actes qui
sont immondes je crois qu'il faut pas
confondent tous les combats et les
Français ont beaucoup de bon sens en
tout cas quand ils sont face à à des des
des des des valeurs qui sont remises en
cause ils se mobilisent ils participent
et vraiment c'est pour moi un vrai sujet
de satisfaction et comme toutes les 5 10
minutes des salves d'applaudissements
retentises dans cette marche Bertrand
pcher vous êtes un homme politique alors
je vous pose la question des polémiques
qui en a eu faut-il manifesté à côté du
RN ou non est-ce que le mot d'ordre est
le juste ou pas qu'est-ce que vous en
avez pensé ben moi écoutez je pense que
il faut remettre toutes les choses à
leur place et qu'on n'est pas là pour
entretenir n'importe toute forme de de
polémique je crois que le pays il a
besoin surtout d'être rassemblé les
débats ils ont lieu dans d'autres cadres
je pense que c'est vraiment pas le
moment aujourd'hui de rajouter de lutte
sur le feu merci beaucoup Bertrand
Pancher président du groupe lotte à
l'Assemblée nationale et puis on
continue cette marche jusqu'au Séna
merci beaucoup merci merci beaucoup Elsa
pour cette interview tout de suite on va
rejoindre Stéphanie des Pierr qui se
trouve avec le député rassemblement
national Jean-Philippe
Tangui Jean-Philippe Tangui bonjour
pourquoi vous êtes là aujourd'hui éz
c'est très simple nous répondons à un
appel d'unité des Françaises et des
Français pour rejeter toutes les formes
de haine et naturellement la la la lutte
soutenir la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
notre pays est défiguré par une vague
d'antisémitisteme depuis plus d'un mois
nous avions la nation avait je pense
trop attendu avant de se réunir et je
nous sommes très heureux de voir que les
Françaises et les Français sont nombreux
àir répondu à l'appel vous avez entendu
tout à l'heure le collectif de militants
le collectif golem qui criait casse-toi
Le Pen les Juifs on ne te veut pas
écoutez on va pas salir une grande
journée d'unité par quelques individus
qui nont de cesse que de vouloir diviser
les Français d'insulter ceux qui veulent
l'unité de la nation mais le passé de
votre parti la condamnation pour
antisémitisme de son fondateur est-ce
que ça ne rend pas votre présence ici
illégitime non mais pas du tout Marine
Le Pen a défini une ligne politique très
claire quand elle a pris le parti il y a
maintenant plus de 15 ans et ça fait
Monsieur Le Pen é exclu en 2015 donc
tout ça ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas
lutté contre l'antisémitisme depuis
qu'ils sont au pouvoir et qui essaient
de diviser la nation au lieu de d'être
cohérent avec ceux qui ont toujours
lutté contre si Marine Le Pen avait été
au pouvoir je pense que la vague
d'antisémitisme que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui n'aurait pas lieu merci
merci Stéphanie Despierre donc avec
Jean-Philippe Tanguy représentant du
rassemblement national présent comme une
quarantaine de députés à cette marche
contre l'antisémitisme Marc Nobel est-ce
que le rassemblement national a toute sa
place à cette marche ou est-ce que ça sa
présence est illégitime comme le pense
la gauche moi vous savez je je je suis
placé passé d'un plateau à un autre et
je n'ai entendu que des polémiques
politiciennes et des choses assez
désagréable il faut le dire moi ce qui
m'intéresse voyez c'est ce qu'il y a
marqué sur cette banderole c'est-à-dire
non à l'antisémitisme et pour les
valeurs de la République et peu importe
qui marche derrière cette banderle ce
qui ne m'intéresse pas ce sont les
polémiques politicienne en tant que tel
qui font que les hommes politiques de
gauche vont tirer sur ceux de droite et
vice-versa moi ce qui m'intéresse ce
sont les gens qui marchent avec le
drapeau français c'est cette sobriété
c'est cette dignité de gens qui ne
scandent pas de slogans aineux qui sont
attachés à leur pays la France qui est
un pays magnifique ce qui m'intéresse
c'est ce que l'on voit dans les fontons
de nos écoles et de no merie liberté
égalité fraternité et sans fraternité il
n'y a pas de justice il n'y a pas de
paix sociale dans notre pays il n'y a
pas d'amour entre les citoyens c'est
cela qui m'intéresse maintenant pour
répondre à votre question chacun pensera
ce qu'il voudra de la présence des uns
et des autres évidemment que cela peut
susciter un problème et un
questionnement de voir l'extrême droite
par exemple ici mais cela suscite
également un questionnement et peut
susciter un large problème que la France
insoumise n'y soit pas et le fait
qu'elle n'y soit pas me semble être une
tâche indélibile Galina Elbas qu'est-ce
que vous pensez du fait que on a entendu
Jean-Philippe Tangui aujourd'hui le
Rassemblement National veut même se
présenter comme le premier rempart
contre l'antisémitisme il dit si Marine
Le Pen était au pouvoir et bien tout
cela n'arriverait pas alors évidemment
moi j'abonde à 400 % à ce que vient de
dire Marc Nobel ce n'est pas une
formation politique qui a une quelconque
légitimité ni crédibilité pour lutter
contre
l'antisémitisme pour
autant moi je refuse de de rentrer dans
des débats sans fin sur la présence de
ce parti dans ce rassemblement
aujourd'hui ce qui m'importe c'est le
succès de ce rassemblement il y a des
milliers et des milliers de Français qui
aujourd'hui sont dans la rue à Paris
dans toutes les grandes villes de notre
pays pour dire non à l'antisémitisme et
ça c'est important c'est ce sont des
Français qui ont justement refusé de
céder à ce chantage qui est qui leur été
fait c'est-à-dire si vous allez
manifester ça veut dire que vous êtes
d'extrême droite non ces Français ne
sont pas d'extrême droite
ça veut dire que vous êtes pro
israélien et justement il y avait une
tenaille c'est si vous allez manifester
ça veut dire que vous vous soutenez le
rassemblement national non ils vont
manifester parce qu'ils lutent contre
l'antisémitisme et si vous allez
manifester je reprends l'immonde tweet
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous soutenez le
massacre à Gaza les Français ont refusé
cette tenaille identitaire qui pourrit
le combat contre l'antisémitisme et qui
pourrit la vie des des Français juifs
aujourd'hui parce que estce que c'est
exactement ce qui fait monter les actes
antisémites an Sophie se bon est-ce que
effectivement jeanluc Mélenchon commet
une faute politique en ne se rendant pas
aujourd'hui à cette manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme je crois qu'on est même
bien au-delà de la faute politique il
commet une faute morale je pense que la
dérive qu'on a vu on la voyait déjà
depuis des semaines depuis des mois mais
la dérive depuis le 7 octobre c'est
tweet à répétition en marge des des
rassemblement propalestinien à l'égard
notamment de la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale que je vois je
vois ici on était vraiment quasiment en
plein dans l'antisémitisme et le fait
qu'ils ne viennent pas et qu'ils aient
pris ce prétexte de la présence du RN
qui est dupe de ce prétexte qu'ils ont
pris pour ne pas venir à ce
rassemblement ce que dit à fi
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ne manifeste pas
contre l'antisémitisme et ce qu'ils
disent par ailleurs tous les autres
jours de la semaine c'est qu'il
nourrissent l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui
dans ce pays enfin sur la polémique je
rejoins complètement ce qui a été dit
par Marc Nobel et et Galina je regrette
vraiment parce qu'on aurait pu manquer
ce rendez-vous avec l'histoire que cette
polémique politique et pris le pas dans
les débats des jours qui l'ont précédé
alors qu'on aurait pu je pense lorsque
le RN a annoncé sa présence la balayer
d'un revers de la main parce que cette
manifestation elle s'est faite à l'appel
de la représentation nationale et de la
même manière que le 11 janvier on all
les défilés sans étiquette pour dire
notre union nationale face face à ce qui
venait de frapper le pays Hollande
l'avait dit à l'époque le président
Hollande l'avait dit à l'époque quand il
commençait à y avoir ce type de
polémique il avait dit j'envoie pas
d'invitation personnelle qui veut venir
vient on on vient à cette manifestation
pour marcher tous dans la même direction
pas pour se regarder h Florent vadilo
que pensez du fait que cette grande
manifestation civique républicaine
d'union et donc virer pour parti hein
car ce n'est pas ce que l'on voit
vraiment aujourd'hui et et virer pour
parti et bien à cette polémique
politique mais moi je serais un peu
différent des trois intervenants qui
m'ont précédé parce que on a tous
commenter l'importance du poids des
symboles le symbole de l'union du
rassemblement de l'affluence et la forme
d'unanimité contre
l'antisémitisme lorsqu'on apprécie les
symboles on ne peut pas faire le choix
dans les victoires symboliqu il y a deux
victoires symboliques l'une infiniment
supérieure à l'autre mais il ne faut en
en écarter aucune l'immense victoire
symbolique c'est ce rassemblement très
fort et puis il a une petite victoire
symbolique c'est la présence du
rassemblement national ça n'est pas une
petite polémique politique cette
manifestation participera à une
normalisation du discours du Front
National et je suis un peu surpris
d'entendre que c'est lié à l'histoire du
Front national non l'antisémitisme
n'appartient pas au folklore du Front
national parce que les personnes qui ont
participé à la campagne de Marine Le Pen
qui ont fait ses appareils de
communication sont liés à des
groupuscules d'extrême droite antisémite
parce que l'entourage proche de Marine
Le Pen parce que David rachelin
notamment dans un livre de votre conceur
les rapasses a été mis en cause
notamment pour son antisémitisme
qualifié de pathologique par certains
acteurs dans le livre de votre conceur
donc ça n'est pas du folklore et encore
une fois le rassemblement national n'a
rompu ni avec les élus qui ont fait
preuve d'antisémitisme et dont certains
ont été condamnés ni avec ses pratiques
ni avec des groupuscules ni avec les
appareils de financement qu'on aille
voir le micro parti de Marine Le Pen
Jeanne qui est trusté par des gens qui
sont condamnés par pour antisémitisme
donc ça n'est pas du folklore et
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est que le
Front national fait cette opération qui
permet d'oublier ce qu'il est
fondamentalement il n'est pas le seul et
c'est là le problème et moi je ne fais
pas de hérarchie des combats je combats
tous les partis politiques qui ont des
complaisances des des culpabilités ou
des formes de de silence autour de
l'antisémitisme mais je ne veux oublier
aucun de ceux qui sont des ennemis et
j'ai du mal à imaginer que des
antisémites défilent aujourd'hui Galina
elle base est-ce qu'il y a une forme de
banalisation du rassemblement national
après cette cette marche avec la
présence du rassemblement national dans
ce cortège al j'adhère pleinement à ce
qui vient d'être dit pour
autant il y a un grand absent dans
l'organisation de ce rassemblement c'est
le mouvement antiraciste si on réfléchit
à la jeunesse du mouvement antiraciste
et toutes les grandes marches qu'il y a
eu en France depuis 20 30 ans elles
étaient structurées par les associations
antiracistes voulez dire à l'initiative
de ce mouvement mais oui la société
civileu des représentants dans le
cortège ils sont dans le cortège mais ce
rassemblement oui mais évidemment mais
ce rassemblement a été organisé par la
la représentation nationale et c'est
très bien mais c'est parce que le le
mouvement les mouvements antiracistes
qu'-ils fait ça fait un mois qu'on a une
recrudescence des acte antisémite en
France de manière absolument
épouvantable ça a été multiplié par tris
euh SOS raciste la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme la Ligue C nous aurions dû et
c'est pas faute pour l'alicra d'avoir
voulu structurer euh une manifestation
mais où sont les associations
antiracistes et je alors je pense que
vous avez peut-être envie de de faire de
faire un un un commentaire sur ce qui se
passe mais je je tiens quand même à dire
que ces
associations ont une part de
responsabilité également elles auraient
dû organiser ce rassemblement et elles
auraient pu tout suite allez on va on va
rejoindre la manifestation à nouveau et
monava car il y a des personnalités en
tout cas dans cette manifestation et
d'ailleurs ela vous êtes avec
l'humoriste et acteur Thom C
oui pour vous c'était important d'être
là aujourd'hui th ouais primordial bien
sûr vous voyez qu'il y a du monde
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous
voyez ce
monde je me dis qu'il y a de l'espoir je
me dis que tout n'est pas perdu je me
dis que on est dans un pays avec des
valeurs
ù j'ai la sensation que la la grande
majorité de la population partage ses
valeurs là et s'ils sont là dans la rue
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils sont prêts à
les défendre ces valeurs et à se battre
pour donc voilà vous avez l'impression
que les polémiques politiciennes ça les
Français les ont pas suivi ceux qui ont
voulu être là aujourd'hui ils ont voulu
être là sans se préoccuper de qui venait
qui venait pas bah oui je pense que ou
oui oui il y a pas d'interdiction à
venir
et je vux vous dire je suis je suis sans
citer de nom toutes les personnes qui
viennent je suis content moi je suis
content si quelqu'un se dit je veux
faire partie de ce cortège je veux faire
partie de cette manipul de manipulation
mon Dieu waouh de de cette manifestation
si je je
de peu importe les
raisons pour moi ils sont les bienvenus
dernière petite question est-ce que
c'est important aussi d'avoir des
personnalités du monde du spectacle vous
êtes connu on en a croisé plusieurs des
acteurs bah voilà de s'engager aussi
aujourd'hui moi moi je le fais pas en
tant qu'artiste euh je le fais en tant
que moi qui je suis c'est-à-dire
euh un gars qui a été naturalisé
français euh qui aime ce pays qui qui
fait sa vie ici j'élève mes enfants ici
j'ai fondé une famille dans ce pays que
j'aime que je chéris je chéris les
valeurs de ce pays je chéris nos
droits et par exemple le droit pour tout
le monde à aller à l'école sans avoir
peur bon voilà donc je suis je
suis je suis je représente pas les
artistes et je me reconnais pas dans une
communauté communauté d'artistes qui se
déplacent pour une manifestation quand
je vois des des collègues avec lesquels
je peux travailler je suis ravi de les
voir mais j'ai pas la sensation qu'on
est là parce qu'on est artiste oui très
bien et ben écoutez merci beaucoup
Thomer cisely citoyen d'avoir répondu à
nos questions pour les chaînes
parlementaires Marc Nobel quand vous
entendez ther cle dire qu'il est là pour
défendre les valeurs républicaine est-ce
que c'est effectivement la République
qui est menacée qui est en danger
aujourd'hui d'abord d'abord j'ai bien
aimé ce qu'il a dit déjà d'une et il me
rassure il me fait plaisir de voir des
artistes des acteurs des humoristes et
et d'autres à cette manifestation dont
je rappelle la dignité cela tranche avec
d'autres manifestations que l'on a vu
ces dernières semaines vous voyez je
regarde votre écran les gens sont calmes
ils manifestent marche gentiment il n'y
a pas de slogan il y a des drapeaux
français c'est un symbole qui est très
fort et magnifique symbole d'une France
apaisée aussi non parce que France est
en violence vous savez moi je ne vois
que cela j'ai un certain âge maintenant
mais j'ai j'ai connu une France plus
apaisée par le
passé la France que je vois de temps en
temps me fait peur c'est-à-dire toute
cette violence dans les réseaux sociaux
cette violence dans la rue cette
violence dans les manifestations ces
gens qui sétripent pour un oui pour un
rien moi ce n'est plus de cela dont j'ai
envie que j'ai envie de voir ce n'est
pas cette France que j'aime j'aime la
France républicaine j'aime les valeurs
de la République j'aime aime une France
qui est fraternelle qui aime ses enfants
tous ses enfants sans distinction quelle
que soit leur religion ou leur origine
et qui prône entre chacun la Concorde la
concorde et la paix civile c'est la
France que j'aime vous voyez et c'est
cette France dont dont nous
parle Thomas celet Thomas celet voouais
je cherchais son nom Thomas celet en
tant que tel et c'est un c'est un
discours qui est bien apaisant et et du
coup je ne m'intéresse pas ni à Marine
Le Pen ni à Eric Zemour ni à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ni à je ne sais qui encore
parce que ce ne sont que les
représentants de parti quelquefois
agités et moi il m'intéresse plutôt de
voir monsieur et madame tout le monde
qui marche pacifiquement qui aime la
République qui aime la France et qui
veulent lutter contre l'antisémitisme et
ou qui voudraiit lutter contre les
discriminations et le racismeina elle
base il y a donc eu une multiplication
des actes antisémites depuis notamment
le 7 octobre vous êtes
avocate aussi euh de quoi parle-t-on
quand on parle de recrudescence des
actes antisémites quels sont les actes
qu'on a vu le plus monter don vous avez
pu vous occuper alors effectivement euh
rien que sur la Licra notre service
juridique a a reçu comme je l'ai déjà
dit sur ce plateau plus de 300 %
d'appels en plus sur des des situations
d'antiséitiste alors c'est tout tous les
les événements de la vie en société des
Français juifs qui sont concernés
c'est-à-dire l'école des injures en dans
les cours de récréation l'université
avec euh des tractes des tags antisémite
ce sont les relations de travail avec
dans les locaux de pause où il y a des
discussions injurieuses ce sont
évidemment les transports en commun avec
euh la rérudescence euh de propos vous
avez tous entendu parler de cette vidéo
de jeunes qui euh faisait un plébiscite
au au à l'action de Hitler et et des
crimes de la Choa des jeunes de 14 15
ans ce sont également des portes de
domicile qui sont dégradés des mousas
qui sont des insignes religieux que
portent les Français juifs devant leur
maison qui sont
arrachés et des violences évidemment une
recrudescence des faits de violence qui
font que c'est une violence verbale mais
aussi physique voilà il y a des propos
mais effectivement des atteintes aussi
en plus peti proportion je tiens à le
dire et heureusement mais principalement
effectivement une déferlante de haine
sur les réseaux sociaux avec des
infractions connexes c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a des propos antisémites mais
aujourd'hui on a surtout euh des propos
d'apologie de terrorisme ce c'est une
glorification des actes du Hamas que
l'on trouve au quotidien par milliers de
contenus sur les réseaux sociaux
derrière la glorification des actes du
ramas c'est la revendication de CRIM à
abominable que l'on connaît des
éventrements des bébés assassinés
israéliens et qui sont revendiqués sur
les r allez on va repartir dans cette
manifestation dans ce cortège et cette
marche pour la République pour vous
retrouver el monangava vous êtes au côté
de Bruno milen député démocrate
desiveline oui grâce à ces images de
thbao Castan Bruno mulien député MoDem
évidemment vous vous ne vous êtes pas
posé la question il fallait venir
aujourd'hui c'était important ah oui trè
très important moi je participe en
général pas aux manifestations parce que
j'ai peur des récupérations politiques
mais là je me suis même pas posé la
question et je suis venu je suis même
pas venu en tant qu'élu en fait pour
tout vous dire je suis venu en tant que
citoyen j'ai laissé l'écharpe à la
maison et je pense que c'est beaucoup
mieux comme ça il fallait que la France
se réveille parce que c'était juste
insupportable ce qui se passe alors on n
pas de chiffre encore sur cette
mobilisation mais on le voit bien le
boulevard Saint-Germain et noir de monde
ça vous rassure de voir que autant de
Français sont descendus dans la rue
aujourd'hui ben je dirais il est temps
parce que les premièes réaction ils
avaient pas été extraordinaires en
faveur de nos amis de confession juivees
et il était temps effectivement qu'on se
réveille et moi je suis très content de
voir que les gens sont venus tous là ici
rassemblés franchement ça fait chaud au
cœur alors on en a beaucoup parlé et
vous êtes un homme politique vous le
savez il y a eu des débats politiques
sur fallait-il marcher ou non fallait-il
accepter le rassemblement national
est-ce que le mot d'ordre était tout à
fait le bon pour vous la meilleure
réponse est dans la rue c'estce que vous
me disiez la meilleure réponse est dans
la rue c'est les gens qui sont autour de
nous moi je me suis écarté les élus sont
devant et vous voyez
G comme vous et MO sont dans la rue ça
c'est la meilleure répon qu'on pit
apporter on s'en fout de savoir de qu
parti on est ce qui est important c'est
qu'on fe citoyené qu'on fasse unité et
que surtout voilà il y a TR mot au front
de bâtiments c'est liberté égalité
fraternité et surtout qu'on rassure nos
amis de confession juif parce qu'en ce
moment ils vivent un enfer merci
beaucoup Bruno milen et puis on entend
la foule qui applaudit toutes les 5 10
minutes une foule plutôt silencieuse qui
continue à se diriger depuis l'Assemblée
nationale vers le Sénat merci merci
beaucoup Elsa Anne Sophie ceon est-ce
que on a entendu un certain nombre de de
personnes qui disaient avoir un petit
peu hésité avant de venir ça pose la
question de savoir si et bien
aujourd'hui afficher bien son soutien la
lutte contre
l'antisémitisme et bien cela peut-être
dangereux est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on
peut avoir des craintes on a entendu des
craintes sur sur la sécurité bien sûr
qui des des Juifs aussi aujourd'hui en
France tout simplement oui évidemment le
sentiment de peur il est il estès
partagé parmi les Français juif mais je
crois parmi la enfin au sein de la
société française plus largement
d'ailleurs il y a un sondage qui avait
été mené une semaine après l'attaque du
7 octobre dans qui a été publié dans le
JDD et qui montre que que une grande
majorité de Français craignaiit qu'une
attaque de ce type et lieu en France
craignait pour eux-mêmees que ce type
d'attaque puisse puisse avoir lieu et
donc on voit et on a connu des attentats
islamistes meurtriers donc il a cette
peur là je pense qui est qui est très
présente et qui et qui explique
l'anxiété qui peut y avoir aussi aller
dans ce genre de semblement tout
simplement au cas où quelque chose
pourrait se se produire évidemment
flurent vadiillot on voit sur ces sur
ces images bien sûr ce cortège qui
marche qui s'arrête de temps en temps
qui chante la Marseillaise qui applaudit
on voit des personnes aux fenêtres
est-ce que vous trouvez qu'il y a un
petit esprit Charlie finalement dans ce
cortège oui je pense que le parallèle
peut-être fait même si chacun récupère
l'esprit Charlie on le voit il faut
d'ailleurs se faire sortir ris de temps
en temps pour qu'il rappelle qui est
Charlie qui ne l''est pas mais
effectivement il y a un parallèle à à
opérer parce que il y a une volonté dans
tous les cas de de promouvoir la
tolérance l'indépendance face à à à tous
les dogmes et et et la seul le seul
dogme qui doit prévaloir qui n est pas
un c'est celui de la Concorde et je
pense que c'est important effectivement
que ce que ce parallèle puisse être
opéré entre les les deux manifestations
parce que c'est à la fois toujours deux
esprits de résistance et çache il faut
rappeler il y a un esprit de résistance
il y a pas de fatalité l'une des
différences qu'il y a avec la
manifestation qu'il y avait eu pour
Charlie c'est qu'il y avait le président
de la République qui était présent
François Hollande à l'époque tandis que
cette fois-ci et bien Emmanuel Macron a
préféré simplement et bien s'exprimer
par une lettre au français pour dire son
soutien mais pour dire aussi qu'il
n'irait pas est-ce que c'est pour vous
regrettable moi ça ne me choque pas je
ne suis pas un turiférire d'Emmanuel
Macron mais ça ne m'a pas choqué pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que en
2015 il y avait une assemblée de chefs
d'État et donc les président de la
République était parmi ses confrères ses
collègues premièrement deuxièmment ça a
été une initiative des deux présidents
des assemblées parlementaires et
j'aurais trouvé que le triangle
présidentassemblée parlementaire et
président de la République auraiit été
quelque peu surprenant j'aurais eu du
mal à imaginer le président de la
République sur les places les marches du
Palais Bourbon pour être pris en photo
c'est un président de la République en
général n'entre pas dans le le périmètre
d'un la séparation des pouvoirs
exactement donc je pense que tout
coïncider pour que le Président de la
République ne soit pas là il a eu des
prises de position qui étaient assez
fortes ces derniers jours y compris à
l'égard du rassemblement national lors
d'une conférence au Grand Orient de
France donc je pense qu'il il n'a pas
d'échu depuis la semaine son absence
n'est à mon avis ni un aveu ni une
complicité il a voulu s'exprimer il le
fait à sa manière et ça ne me choque pas
on on retourne à présent au cœur de
cette marche pour la République et
contre l'antisémitisme els mondingava
vous êtes avec Karine l mararchand
animatrice de télévision
oui vous êtes venu avec votre drapeau
français ce drapeau votre présence
cétait important aujourd'hui oui c'est
important parce que ce qui se passe en
ce moment en France est dangereux on on
doit montrer que la France a des valeurs
très fortes qu'elle a une histoire où
n'oublions pas il y a eu autant de
collabo qui a eu aussi des justes et
c'était il y a pas si longtemps et ça me
semble fondamental aujourd'hui de dire à
tous les Juifs qui se sentent en danger
qu'on est là et que c'est pas la France
qu'on veut et qu'on veut une France qui
aime tous les Français quel que soit
leur religion leur origine de naissance
leur préférence sexuelle le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron il est pas
là aujourd'hui est-ce que vous vous
auriez aimé bah le voir en tête de
cortège j'aurais aimé le voir là ou au
moins sa femme parce que si lui dit que
le président n' n'a pas à manifester en
tout cas souvent il envoie sa femme pour
des év qui me semble beaucoup moins fort
en terme de valeur maintenant il fait ce
qu'il veut et et voilà et là le fait de
voir du monde est-ce que ça vous rassure
est-ce que ça vous fait plaisir et puis
aussi il pleut pas ça compte en fait les
conditions sont un peu réunies
aujourd'hui je crois pas que les gens
soient soient venus parce qu'il pleut
pas je pense qu'il serait venu autant
s'il pleuvait moi j'ai mon bonnet mes
gants j'étais
prête on est là je crois que les réseaux
sociaux c'est de la grosse merde il faut
le dire et que ce qu'on voit dans les
réseaux sociaux n'est pas à la mesure de
ce que pensent les Français
je ne crois pas que les Français soient
si racistes et si antisémit simplement
on ne donne pas la parole à ces gens-là
et donc là c'était pour ça que c'était
important qu'on soit là pour montrer que
c'est pas c'est pas ça la vraie vie
c'est pas ça ce qu'on pense on aime tout
le monde on veut une France apaisée et
je vois pas pourquoi quelqu'un qui sera
né ici de parents juifs se sent en
relation avec ce qui se passe dans un
conflit Isra pasen c'est n'importe quoi
voilà merci beaucoup pour ce cri du cœur
animatrice et citoyenne Karine Le
Marchand merci beaucoup Elsa et Karine l
marchand avec son drapeau bleu blanc
rouge et tout de suite on va rejoindre
Quentin Quentin calm également en direct
de cette marche car vous êtes et bien
avec notamment Boris Vallot le député
socialiste et la sénatrice écologiste
des Français de l'étranger Mélanie
Vogel voilà donc c'est la délégation en
fait des élus socialistes écologistes et
communistes qui font et bien front
commun tous ensemble et signe qu'il y a
du monde cette délégation vient
seulement de passer et bien l'Assemblée
nationale donc effectivement le signe
qu'il y a pas mal de monde du moins de
là où on se trouve oner rejoindre Boris
Vallot bonjour Boris Vall président du
groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale on voit ces applaudissements
ce monde on
pe on peut qu' du monde on se réjou pas
évidemment d'être obligé d'être dans la
rue aujourd'hui mais règne un esprit de
fraternité et de con qui fait du bien
mais après ce jour de manifestation il
faudra pas baisser la garde voilà je
crois que c'est une forme de rappel à
l'ordre mais qui doit sonner à notre
porte chaque matin et alors vous vouliez
faire vous un cordon républicain contre
le rassemblement national qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire exactement ça veut dire
quand le président deem n pasable
deonnaître un antisémite pluss n
[Rires]
pas vous le voulez bien mais l'absence
d'Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce que ça
vousés aujourd'hui écoutez il a envoyé
ce matin français message de quiti à
cette
socialiste parce que effectivement la
liaison est très mauvaise ce qu'on a
compris c'est qu'il y avait cet esprit
de de fraternité Marc Knobel cette
France résistante qui était dans la rue
cet après-midi on entendait Karine Le
Marchand dire c'est de la merde les
réseaux
est-ce que finalement la France
silencieuse celle-ci qui déverse pas sa
haine sur sur les réseaux elle est là
dans la rue et elle fait entendre sa
voix
aujourd'hui là vous voyez c'est la
France de la fraternité de l'amour et il
faut opposer cette France là à ceux et
celles qui haïs ils se servent des
réseaux sociaux pour déverser leur haine
à longueur de tweite et en fait s'ils le
font il faut bien comprendre pourquoi
ils le font c'est parce qu'ils sont
anonymisés ils utilisent des pseud on il
n'y a pas de modération les plateformes
s'en fichent réellement et c'est pour
cela que vous avez cette flambé de
violence tel qu'on la constate
aujourd'hui dans les réseaux sociaux et
tel que je l'ai analysé dans deux livres
que j'ai publié à ce sujet et ce qui me
désespère c'est le silence des
plateformes qui ne pensent qu'à faire de
l'argent et n'ont aucune éthique en tête
c'est le silence qui a été celui des
pouvoirs publics pendant longtemps de
laisser les choses ainsi s'installer
c'est la violence qui gangraine notre
société y compris dans les réseaux
sociaux à coup de menace et d'injure on
ne parle pas on ne débat pas on crie on
ve s'y faire alors il y a quand même la
une législation qui est en place pour
réguler ces ces plateformes c'est pas
suffisant selon vous il faudrait aller
encore plus loin peut-être stopper
l'anonymat sur les réseaux sociaux
stopper l'anonymat me semble une
condition indispensable c'est-à-dire
quand on est connecté sur X et quand
l'on regarde le déchaînement de violence
qu'il y a après que un poste a été
publié c'est-à-dire des fois des
centaines et des centaines de
commentaires haineux crapuleux injurieux
menaçant ce n'est plus possible en
vérité ou alors on marche sous des œufs
où on est devenu fou notre société
devenu folle moi je ne me contente pas
du peu je me contente toujours du plus
et quand il y a de la haine il faut
savoir lutter et se battre contre la
haine et j'oppose à la haine cette
France fraternelle vous voyez là l'image
je vois un drapeau français ça me
rassure je ne vois pas absolument je ne
vois pas de pancarte haineuse je
n'entends pas de slogan horrible je ne
vois pas de gens qui veulent en découdre
mais simplement de gens qui veulent
protéger la République kalalina Elbas
effectivement il faut donc se méfier
aussi parfois du prisme déformant des
réseaux sociaux où règne l'invective et
qui ne reflète pas forcément l'opinion
des Français et et c'est aussi et bien
une manifestation du fait fait que la
France n'est pas antisémite et réagit
contre l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui oui
je rappelais tout à l'heure le les
chiffres du du baromètre he qui est
publié chaque année par la CNCDH ils
sont importants parce que quand on on
les analyse il y a près de 70 % des
Français qui considèrent que la lutte
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme est
une cause nationale majeure à pour
laquelle il faut se battre pour
autant on on nous pose toujours la
question de savoir pourquoi les actes
antisémites augmentent ce que ce que
j'analyse moi c'est qu'en réalité ils
Aug ils augmentent parce qu'ils sont euh
l'expression d'une minorité très
agissante en revanche très agissante qui
qui aujourd'hui n'est pas celle qui
défile dans la rue alors j'entendais
Marc Nobel nous dire que l'anonymat est
un fléo sur les réseaux sociaux c'est un
fléo effectivement parce que derrière
son compte Twitter on peut agir
impunément déverser sa haine le fait
qu'on soit pas anonyme aussi est un fléo
les grands animateurs des réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui qui qui qui diluent
leur haine sur les par à coup de twit et
qui font et un marketing financier et un
marketing politique de Lorine sont aussi
des députés de la nation française je
tiens à dire quand même que bon voilà
les les comptes Twitter et de David
guireud et de Mathilde Panau de la
France insoumise sont des comptes en
référence aussi au dérapage du député la
France insoumiss David guireud qui était
vivement critiqué pour avoir tenu des
propos minimisants l'attaque du Hamas du
7 octobre dernier voil ça c'est
scandaleux un député de de la République
française alors effectivement il est pas
là aujourd'hui évidemment qu'il n'est
pas là aujourd'hui David guirot ni sa
formation politique euh on en parlait
tout à l'heure ils sont sortis de l'
l'Arque républicain je n'ai pas entendu
de condamnation ferme de son groupe
politique il y en a pas je précise que
David guireot a ironisé sur des des
bébés brûlés sur des femmes éventré BB
dans un en attribuant à Israël en
attribuant à israëlle par inversion
accusatoire le fait de brûler ou de ou
de tuer des femmes euh ça vous dites que
la France est insoumise aujourd'hui en
en ne condamnant pas cautionne cet
antisémitisme vous iriez jusque- là il y
a une expression de de l'historien
Emmanuel de benau que je trouve
extrêmement juste il indique que il y a
une forme d'antisémitisme électoral à la
France insoumise moi je ne dis pas que
la France insoumise est antisémite je
dis que certains font de l'antisémitisme
un carburant électoral une stratégie une
stratégie clientéliste que d'autres sont
profondément
antisémite et antisioniste parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une une une
corrélation entre l'antisionisme la
haine de l'État d'Israël qui est l'état
du peuple juif et la montée de
l'antisémitisme et je crois qu'on peut
pas faire l'impasse sur aussi c'est
cette problématique là Ann Sophie ce
est-ce que vous diriez que
l'antisémitisme a changé de camp qu'il
est passé de l'extrême droite à
l'extrême gauche aujourd'hui je dirais
pas ça non plus mais c'est vrai qu'on
voit deux stratégies qui s'opposent
c'estàdire celle de la fis intéressante
cette expression de d'antisémitisme
électoral ils vont effectivement très
loin et le fait qu'ils ne viennent pas
je veux dire c'est un marqueur
extrêmement fort qui devrait scandaliser
tous les Français et à l'inverse on a le
rassemblement national et on il s'agit
pas de sous-estimer leur stratégie mais
qui est inverse qui est de se normaliser
et pour eux finalement l'antisémitisme
c'est le dernier verrou s'ils
réussissent à faire sauter ce verrou
c'est ils ont réussi leur normalisation
de la normalisation de de l'image de ce
parti et et et pour finir là-dessus
pour parler de la marche d'aujourd'hui
si LFI étaient venu à cette marche
scandale aussi enfin je veux dire ces
gens depuis le 7 octobre comme comme le
disait Galina base tweet des choses
abominables on va préciser quand même
que certains représentants de LFI ont
été présent à cette marche notamment en
province à
Strasbourg
clémentinetin Alex cor Raquel garido
donc voilà quand même que certains ont
participé à cette marcheanitisme mieux
je ve dire je je pense que si Jean-Luc
Mélenchon était quand même venu à cette
manifestation ça aurait été un scandale
parce qu'il est carrément ouvertement
antisémite aujourd'hui mais est-ce que
ça aurait obligé chacun à se positionner
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de cela mais vous
Dirz qu'il est antisémite ou ou que
c'est un calcul politique électorale
pour ramener à lui cet électorat
musulman moi je suis pas je je je sais
pas son des les âmes je sais pas ce
qu'il a en son âme et conscience mais
mais ce que je sais c'est ce qu'il dit
et ce qu'il dit frô
vraiment vraiment l'antisémitisme je ve
dire son tweet sur rappelle qu' av dit
camp encourager les massacres on est
quand même vraiment on est làdedans et
il sait très bien jouer avec les mots et
qui a dit les amis du soutien
inconditionnel au massacre ont leur
rendez-vous c'était sa première réaction
après et bien l'annonce de cette marche
par Bron PIV comme s'il y avait
finalement une confusion entre la
présence à cette marche et la défense
un amalgame qui est fait tout à fait
mais ce qu'il veut faire c'est c'est
c'est c'est le piège dans lequel
certains sont tombés c'est-à-dire de
dire on a aujourd'hui l'extrême droite
qui manifeste avec les Juifs mais c'est
mais c'est scandaleux il est en train de
de de de diviser la France en deux et
c'est là où personnellement la présence
du président qu'il soit là ou pas là
pour des raisons protocolaires pourquoi
pas mais moi ce qui m'a plus gêné c'est
les raisons qui qui ont été rapportées
qui ont justifié son absence et quand on
j'ai élu qu'il aurait dit qu'il que que
ça crainte parce qu'il y a une
hésitation dans les derniers jours de
savoir s' allait venir ou pas c'est la
crainte de de s'adresser à une France
coupé en deux je crois qu'il y a un
problème de compréhension totale par
rapport à ce qu'on vient de se dire sur
l'importance de cette marche son
caractère républicain universel cette
démonstration de tous les fr CR d'être
assimilé à un camp comment dire Emmanuel
Macron s'il et bien participait à cette
marche et de ne plus être dans cette
position d'équilibre qui souhaitait
c'est ce qui a été rapporté quoi mais
mais c'est scandaleux on est là pour
marcher pour la République et contre
l'antisémitisme en je veux dire c'est là
que je disais tout à l'heure on aurait
pu balayer d'un revers de la main
l'annonce de la présence du RN puce que
qui aurait pu s'étonner qu'ils allent
annoncé être présent ça fait partie de
leur stratégie depuis des mois quand le
groupe de travail à l'Assemblée
nationale sur antisémitisme a été créé
ils se sont précipités pour essayer d'en
prendre la présidence on sait que ça
fait partie de leur stratégie mais je
veux dire on aurait pu dire ils veulent
venir on n'est pas DUP qu' restent o où
ils sont mais le fait qu'on est fait une
polémique mais qu'est-ce qui a créé la
polémique finalement c'est l'annonce de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de dire que lui il ne
viendrait pas et c'est comme si lui
avait poussé finalement tout le monde à
se positionner par rapport à ça alors
que c'est lui le scandale c'est lui qui
est en train de nous dire que son parti
ne marche pas contre l'antisémitisme et
c'est ce piège dans lequel il aurait
fallu que tout le monde évite de tomber
dans ce grand moment de stratégie
Florent vadillot qu'est-ce qui tire les
marrons du feu est-ce que le
rassemblement national là est en train
de de réussir à achever son processus de
normalisation est-ce que qui qui qui
est-ce qui est en train de marqu qu des
points auprès de de son électorat puce
qu'on parle stratégie là d'abord seul
les élections permettront de d'en tirer
des enseignements il y en a l'année
l'année prochaine en juin 2024 les
élections européennes ensuite il faut
toujours se méfier des sondages mais
néanmoins lorsque vous avez un an voire
18 mois de sondages qui sont conformes
c'est clairement le rassemblement
national aujourd'hui le le sondage qui
vient de sortir de de l'Ifop le place le
rassemblement national à 29 %
d'intention de vote aux élections
européennes le deuxième parti après lui
c'est 22 % c'est renaissances 22 % du du
président de la République donc c'est
c'est ça me paraît totalement démesuré
vous avez 89 députés rassemblement
national à l'Assemblée nationale lorsque
il y avait eu le jeu de la
proportionnelle sous François mitteran
c'était moins d'une dizaine de
parlementaires qui étaient entrés vous
avez des villes qui sont tenues par le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui vous
avez un parti politique dont le fond de
commerce je permets de le rappeler est
basé sur la haine la haine des musulmans
en ce moment mais l'avantage du
rassemblement national c'est que les
haines ne sont pas exclusives et donc
c'est ce qu'il partage le mieux au monde
mais la haine du Juif qui se cache parce
qu'en ce moment il faut qu'elle se cache
mais je pense vraiment que c'est un
parti de haine qui a fondé son son
asscension politique sur la haine et qui
aujourd'hui est un parti qui est crédité
dans toutes les enquêtes d'opinion non
seulement d'intention de vote mais de
respectabilité et de capacité à
gouverner il est là le problème alors
toute une partie de la gauche est
également présent
justement à l'écart du rassemblement
national dans un cordon républicain et
Quentin Calmet et justement et bien avec
ces personnalités de gauche et notamment
Mélanie Vogel sénatrice écologiste des
Français de l'étranger
Quentin oui bonjour Mélanie Vogel
c'était important d'être réuni
socialiste écologiste et communiste
autour d'une même bandeerole évidemment
que c'est important au moment où les
actes antisémites sont en progression
terrifiante en France ù nos compatriotes
juives et juifs ont peur c'est notre
responsabilité historique politique de
marcher ensemble contre l'antisémitisme
donc contre le racisme contre la haine
et donc contre l'extrême droite aussi il
manque une déformation de la Nupe la
France insoumise on le comprend elle n'a
pas souhaité participer elle n'aurait
pas été le bienvenu aussi derriè cette
banderole qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
non je crois que c'est c'est un choix
que je partage pas qui consiste à
considérer que
on déserte certaines luttes parce que le
rassemblement national les
instrumentalise au profit du racisme et
nous au contraire nous pensons l'inverse
nous pensons que oui aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national a une stratégie
qui consiste à instrumentaliser la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme à des fins
racistes et notre responsabilité c'est
pas de les laisser faire c'est pas de
les laisser occuper cet espace c'est au
contraire d'affirmer qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes là aussi pour marcher contre eux
contre tout ce qu'ils porte et alors
justement une dernière question on le
sait que plus loin dans le cortège il y
a des élus du rassemblement national une
quarantaine de parlementaires qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque des facto de marché
au même rassemblement que ça m'évoque ce
que je viens de vous dire c'est une
stratégie pensée de la part de l'extrême
droite il ne sont pas en train de
marcher contre l'antisémitisme ils sont
en train d'essayer d'utiliser notre
lutte pour la dignité humaine pour
l'égalité des droits à des fins euh
racistes et donc je veux leur dire ceux
qui sont derrière ceux qui sont devant
et tous celles et ceux qui militent en
extrême droite voulaient marcher
aujourd'hui que c'est aussi contre eux
contre leur idéologie que nous sommes
toutes et tous rassemblés et bien merci
merci Mélanie Vogel sénatrice écologiste
des fris établie hors de France
notreaction micro de plusena et dlcp
merci Quentin Calmet Galina
base vice-présidente de de la Licra
avocate est-ce que vous trouvez qu'on
lutte efficacement contre
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous trouvez qu'il devrait y avoir
davantage de condamnations ce qu' en a
une trentaine sur les 1250 actes qui ont
été répertoriés depuis le 7 octobre
alors je vais vous répondre juste à un
petit mot parce que je voudrais pas
qu'on qu'on se méprenne aussi sur le
positionnement qui est le nôtre et qui
est très ferme sur la présence du du
rassemblement national on on lutte pas
contre contre l'antisémitisme on lutte
contre l'antisémitisme sur ses deux
jambes donc le rassemblement national
est un parti qui n'a aucune légitimité à
lutter contre l'antisémitisme dans notre
pays il faut que ce soit bien dit
j'approuve absolument ce qui ce qui
vient d'être dit et la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme elle ne se divise pas ça
c'est sûr mais elle ne doit jamais être
instrumentalisé à des fins à des fins de
lutte contre à des fins de stratégie
politiqueou de récupération Politi de
récupération politique pour cibler des
concitoyens qu'il soient qu'il soient
maghrébain arabau musulmans ça c'est une
chose importante que je tiens à dire sur
la sur la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
au niveau J
et oui ça va beaucoup trop lentement ça
va beaucoup trop lentement parce que on
l'a dit l'anonymat des réseaux sociaux
il faut une farmé absolu il y a les
sanctions les
sanctions judiciaires appropriées qui
doivent être rendues fermement et sur
les les grandes plateformes c'est des
plateformes qui font de l'argent qui qui
monétisent qui font de du racisme et de
la haine une source de une source une
source de financement et bien il faut
les San commerce du racisme et de
l'antisémitisme et bien nous ne cessons
de le dire quand on fait un fond de
commerce de la haine et bien on doit
payer cher ces condamnations il faut
avoir le courage de de de toucher au
portefeuille ces plateformes qui ne
vivent que qui ne vivent que du du
succès marketing de la haine et puis
s'agissant des des actes on a besoin
cruellement de magistrats de greffi et
de magistrats formés à ces questions on
va écouter un instant cette marseillaise
qui reten à nouveau les T
sanglantlevés les tard sanglantlev
entendez-vous dans nos
[Musique]
campagnes F
soldat qui vienent jusque dans nos B et
quand nos fils et nos
compagnes aux
cit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bataillons
marchons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marchons C marseillaise qui retentit
donc pour la la deuxème fois au cours de
cette marche pour la République et
contre l'antisémitisme Mac Nobel on voit
cette unité de nos responsables
politiques et de de l'ensemble des
citoyens qui marche et qui défile
aujourd'hui c'est un peu le triomphe de
la République sur le racisme sur
l'antisémitisme le triomphe de la
République ce sera quand il n'y aura
plus
d'antisémitisme ce n'est pas le cas
malheureusement et l'antisémitisme va se
poursuivre après cette
manifestation quand on regarde ce qu'il
en est des actes
1247 actes comptabilisés en un
mois je voudrais rappeler deux chiffres
936 actes comptabilisé en 2002 974 en
2004 et
1247 en un mois cela va continuer et il
faut que cela s'arrête et pour que cela
s'arrête il faut que ce que nous avons
ici se poursuive c'est-à-dire la réunion
de gens modérés qui en ont assez que la
France soit soué tandis que l'on voit et
bien la tête de cortège qui qui qui qui
termine en fait cette marche car on est
tout près là du Sénat on va rejoindre
Elsa mondingava qui se trouve avec Ellie
shurakiy oui réalisateur qui a la
gentillesse de nous guider thibo Castan
et moi-même dans cette manifestation
pour vous c'était important d'être
aujourd'hui dans la rue d'envoyer quel
message qu'il faut lutter contre les
ténèbres ça en fait tous ces gens qui
sont là luttent contre les écoutez les
applaudissements on vient de chanter la
Marseillaise les gens applaudisent et
c'est ça c'est
que l'antisémitisme c'est le c'est
l'obscurité c'est le noir c'est c'est
c'est vraiment quelque chose contre
lesquel il faut lutter quel que soit son
parti de gauche à droite de l'extrême
gauche à l'extrême droite en passant par
le centre tout le monde doit lutter
contre ça pour tenir la France pour
tenir la démocratie et pour respecter
les règles que la démocratie nous dicte
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
se sont interrogés fallait-il venir
aujourd'hui avec la présence des élus du
rassemblement national en fonction du
mot d'ordre est-ce le bon mot d'ordre
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites vous savez
vous avez un homme qui est au milieu du
Torr d'un torrent qui est en train de se
noyer peut-être et et vous posez la
question de savoir s'il faut plonger ou
pas ah oui mais il y a l'autre sur
l'utre qui va pas plonger moi je plonge
il faut plonger il faut plonger parce
qu'il faut se battre contre ça il faut
aller vers cet homme qui se noit et lui
dire je suis là ne t'inquiète pas bon je
rassure monsieur mélenchant les Juifs
savent nager mais en dehors de ça je
crois que la parabole est assez claire
est-ce qu'il aurait fallu qu'Emmanuel
Macron soit là aujourd'hui bien sûr bien
sûr c'est même embarrassant qu'il soit
pas là c'est embarrassant pour lui bon
je vous savez les les grands hommes je
pense à de GA à Churchill se révèle
toujours dans les grandes batailles
j'aurais aimé que le président notre
président qui nous présente tous se
révèle aussi dans cette grande bataille
mais il n'est pas trop tard on est au on
est au merci il est pas trop tard on est
au début du chemin je pense que il va
rejoindre ces grands hommes et et à
nouveau être au cœur de ce que la
République nous demande merci beaucoup
Ie shuraki regardez derrière on voit le
cordon avec les élus et cette
marseillaise qui retentit je vous la
laisse écouter la
Marseillaise merci monsieur
voilà cette marseillaise qui est retenti
à
nouveau on va s'approcher un peu deelon
de ce cortège et de cette marche alors
que le le carré tête est arrivé au bout
de la manifestation plate placé de mon
Rostan donc tout près du du Sénat parti
des Invalides à 15h on va retrouver
Quentin Calmet qui lui est dans cette
marche au côté d'un citoyen qui est venu
marcher cet après-midi
oui tout à fait je crois que je suis au
milieu moi du du cortège à peu près au
au milieu et on vient seulement de
passer la rue de l'Université donc on
est encore très près de l'Assemblée
nationale signe qu'il y a du monde
aujourd'hui même s'il est difficile de
dire combien de personnes sont
rassemblées à Paris je suis avec Patrice
bonjour Patrice on vient d'entendre
après les applaudissements après les
Marseillaises des slogan libérer les
otages libérer les enfants pourquoi
avoir scandé aussi ces paroles-là car
aujourd'hui vu ce qui se passe dans la
bande de Gaza nous avons des citoyens
français nos concitoyens français qui
sont euh pris en otage actuellement et
en tant que citoyen français quoi que
soit la confession religieuse quoi que
soit qu' soit até ou n'importe quoi il
faut revendiquer ceci et ça me fait
plaisir aujourd'hui de voir beaucoup
beaucoup de gens dans la rue
effectivement je pense qu'il y a une
prise de conscience des citoyens
français et on se devait d'être là et
c'est nous qui avons œuvré pour faire
scander ce ce mouvement et qui a été
sensible et repris tout au cours de la
manif et bien merci effectivement il y a
h français qui sont toujours partés
disparus peut-être kidnappé par le Hamas
effectivement merci merci beaucoup
Quentin et une autre réaction politique
euh celle de Éric soti le président des
républicains qui se trouve avec els
mandingava
oui vous venez d' d'entonner avec
d'autres élus la Marseillaise pour vous
quel est le sens de ce rassemblement
c'est
euh défendre promouvoir les valeurs
universelles de la République c'est
exprimé un révolte contre la montée de
l'antisémitisme et c'est dire que la
France est ici dans l'expression des
valeurs les plus fortes qu'elle doit
défendre et que tous ceux qui sont
attachés à ces valeurs sont ici
aujourd'hui pour dire non à
l'antisémitisme le chef de l'État
soutient à distance auriez-vous souhaité
qu'Emmanuel Macron soit là oui je lui ai
demandé je regrette son absence pour moi
cette absence est une faute parce que
quand on est chef de l'État chef d'une
nation qui doit dire dans l'unité un
message de combat contre
l'antisémitisme ne pas s'y associer ou
donner le sentiment d'un en même temps
ambigu n'est n'est pas à la hauteur de
du moment et de la gravité du moment
donc ne pas être là de la part de chef
de l'État est une faute il y a du monde
Eric Coti est-ce que ça vous rassure de
voir cette image qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de voir tous ces français réunis
aujourd'hui je crois que la France dans
son immense majorité combat
l'antisémitisme est attaché à la défense
de ses valeurs essentielles il y a des
voix qui ont fait mal à la France il y a
des attitudes il y a des propos qui sont
indignes qui sont honteux ceux qui ne
sont pas là ceux qui ce matin ont essayé
de quelque part par leur messages ambigu
de de profaner de récupérer le veldive
et bien tout cela ils sont infiniment
minoritaires la France aujourd'hui elle
est là merci beaucoup éti président des
républicains merci beaucoup monangava et
vous voyez la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationalezvous cet appel a été lancé
mardi dans la presse nous en avons
décidé du principe lundi dernier c'était
il y a simplement 6 jours et moi je
voudrais vous dire que c'est
extrêmement réjouissant de voir
qu'aujourd'hui en France nous sommes
capables de nous rassembler aussi
rapidement de nous réunir
autour de ce qui fait notre socle de ce
qui a fait notre histoire et ce qui fera
j'en suis sûre notre avenir et moi je
suis extrêmement confiante parce que
aujourd'hui nous avons montré la plus
belle image de la France tous ensemble
quel que soient nos partis politiques
quel que soi nos parcours politiques et
c'est aussi ça que nous voulions montrer
avec le président du Sénat et moi-même
que nous avions tout dépassé pour
pouvoir nous rassembler pour ce qui
était de plus précieux je suis heureuse
nous sommes heureux que nos concityens a
répondu très largement à cet appel car
c'est avant tout pour eux que nous avons
marché je vous
remercie voilà pour cette prise de
parole et cette embrassade entre yel
brun Pivet et Gérard Larcher à
l'initiative de cette la rép et contre
l'antisémitisme une France remblée qui a
répondu à l'appel on va entendre à
présent la première ministreisabeth
Bor
je de très nombreux citoyens sont
Mobilis pour répondre à l par président
du sén et la présidente de
l'assembléeidé pouri
d'êtrec
pour dire que la République doit
protéger tous ces citoyens que nul ne
peut être inquiété en raison de son
origine et de sa religion et le
gouvernement avec tous les ministres
nous voulons dire à NS concitoyens de
religion juiv que nous sommes à leur
côté nous sommes mobilisés que nous ne
laisserons rien passer il y aura des
démarches derrière c'est ce qu' dit le
président larch pas seulement une marche
mais des démarches qu'est-ce qu'il veut
dire le présidentarch expliquera les
démarches qu'il tête je peux vous dire
c'est que les policiers les gendarmes
les magistrats sont très mobilisés pour
ne laisser passer aucun message de haine
pour ne laisser évidemment pas passer
aucune violence à l'égard d'un de nos
concitoyens parce qu'il est de religion
juive donc on est on ne laisse rien
passer on est au côté de nos concitoyens
de religion merci Madame merci
beaucoupcp voilà Elisabeth borne qui
s'est exprimé à la fin de ce cortège
avec son gouvernement qui était présent
environ 25 ministres qui ont défilé cet
après-midi une marche et des démarches a
promis Gérard Larché c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est plutôt rassuré par
ce ce ce rassemblement avec ces Français
qui sont venus nombreux mais il y a le
jour d'après euh et il faudra lutter
encore contre l'antisémitisme oui bien
sûr et comme on le disait tout à l'heure
l'antisémitisme Marc Nobel a dit c'est
une maladie si on avait le remède
miracle contre cette maladie on l'aurait
transmis au gouvernement c'est un combat
de de de longue haline nous ce dont on
est convaincu c'est que pour lutter
efficacement contre ce fléo et ça
commencera demain enfin ça continuera
demain c'est de mettre en place une
politique de tolérance zéro la tolérance
zéro elle se joue à différents niveaux
c'est d'abord la parole publique des
condamnations très ferme et immédiate on
voit aujourd'hui dans la parole
politique il y a malheureusement un
morcelllement il faut il faut
retravailler là-dessus c'était pas le
cas il y a encore quelques années mais
on doit travailler là-dessus c'est la
réponse sécuritaire évidemment là on a
vu comme le ministère de l'intérieur est
très mobilisé c'est la réponse
judiciaire Galine Albas en a longuement
parlé et c'est la mobilisation de toute
la société c'est ce qu'on espère voir
aujourd'hui c'est des moyens qui doivent
être mis en œuvre si ça nous concerne
tous il faut que dans le secteur
éducatif beaucoup plus de moyens soit
mis pour déconstruire les préjugés pour
aller plus loin pour savoir identifier
les différentes formes de
l'antisémitisme pour éduquer les
professeurs les les magistrats les juges
tous les secteurs de la société sont
concernés et et je crois qu'on a encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire en la matière
on va dire oui beaucoup de chemins à
faire pour passer du symbole au fait
aujourd'hui pour manifester à tous les
niveaux cette intransigence vis-à-vis de
l'antisémitisme oui c'est c'est
indéniable il y a très clairement sur la
répression judiciaire un mieux à espérer
les voies législatives sont assez minces
il il faut le dire l'apologie du
terrorisme a été sortie de la loi sur la
liberté de la presse on on pourrait
imaginer des des des des pratiques
identiques mais après ce qui compte ce
sont des équipes d'enquêteurs parce que
en fait l'administration de la preuve
est souvent compliquée lente incertaine
et puis plus de mobilisation de la part
des des magistrats évidemment non pas
qu'il y ait une passivité de la part de
la justice il y a un problème de manque
de moyens de manque de mobilisation et
effectivement vous l'avez très justement
dit à plusieurs reprises tout n'est pas
du côté répressif je pense qu'il y a
aujourd'hui dans la société française
des discours qui se sont construits sur
des haines à la fois culturelles
cultuelles et puis des mécaniques qui
empreunent au discours complotiste et le
Juif de ce point de vue-là est souvent
la clé de compréhension pour les
complotistes parce que c'est une excuse
facile et donc je pense qu'il faut
déconstruire l'ensemble de ces discours
de de qui sont des parfois abordés avec
un silence coupable donc ça passe par
quoi par l'éducation ça passe ça passe
par l'éducation et ça passe aussi je
crois on l'a dit sur les réseaux sociaux
par le fait de démonter systématiquement
la rhtorique complotiste qui est en
train de parfois de de prendre germe et
très puissante he c'est difficile he on
sait le combat contre le auourd'i CH
c'est un choix je je me permets de de il
faut il faut mettre en balance deux
éléments aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux
ont une capacité marketing très forte
avec un taux de transformation réel ce
qui fait aujourd'hui la la puissance
financière c'est que le choix a été fait
pour que il y ait une capacité justement
de de soutenabilité financière je ne
vois pas l'équivalent pour démonter les
réseaux complotistes lutter contre
l'antisémitisme on a publié récemment le
nombre de de modérateurs qu'il y avaient
sur la plateforme x Twitter quand on
voit les langues euh qui sont sollicités
je crois deux modérateurs pour la langue
hébraïque 12 pour l'arabe euh 55 en
France il faut se poser des questions
sur l'obligation de ils ont fait l'objet
d'un gros plan social d'Éon musk hein
c'est la première chose qui a été
retirée la modération he exactement on
ne peut pas à un moment donné ce sont
des entreprises commerciales comme les
autres avec des autorisations
d'exploitation de réseau physique même
si c'est du numérique il y a du physique
je pense qu' il y a des bénéfices très
forts Twitter X est en train d'en perdre
mais enfin il gagne quand même de
l'argent il y a des choix qui ont été
faits il ne faut pas laisser ces choix
impunis et donc le fait qu'il n'y ait
plus de modération qu'il ait une
modération moindre que la polarisation
soit devenue un facteur de
fonctionnement de X doit être clairement
une réflexion démocratique pas au niveau
français et même pas au niveau
uniquement européen et j'en finis en
disant le président Biden a annoncé des
mesures très fortes sur la régulation de
l'intelligence artificiel quand on veut
il y a une volonté il y a des capacités
d'action et bien j'attends la même chose
sur les réseaux sociaux sur cette
mécanique de la haine parce que la
polarisation conduit souvent à la haine
et à la réussite de ces réseaux sociaux
vous dites que ça va au-delà de la
France effectivement on sait qu'au
niveau européen il y a une régulation
qui est en train de se se mettre en
place Marc Nobel est-ce que vous pensez
que Thierry Breton peut fédérer autour
de lui pour réussir à à combattre Elon
Musk on sait que il y a des discussions
avec la plateforme X qui sont son très
très tendu justement pour réguler ces
réseaux sociaux et bien cela a été dit
il y a un instant il y a 52 modérateurs
francophones pour 13 millions
d'utilisateurs français et encore je ne
vous parle pas des autres millions
d'utilisateurs francophone dans le monde
en fait ils sont 52 c'est une mascara
dans ce fiche du monde donc il y a un
moment il va falloir taper sur le du
point sur la table et taper dans le
porte-monnaie en fait parce que ce
son absolument ce n'est que la seule
chose qu'ils comprennent quand on touche
au porte-monnaie et là ils ont peur ils
changent ils changent d'attitude parce
que en vérité permettez-moi de le dire
ils sont arrogants et ils sont arrogants
parce qu'ils veulent faire de l'argent
et ils se fichent de l'éthique et ça
c'est inacceptable maintenant combattre
l'antisémitisme le racisme l'homophobie
dans les réseaux sociaux c'est très bien
mais il faut donner des moyens à l'école
c'est parler éducation que les choses
bougeront les profs sont seuls
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile pour
les profs sachez-le c'est très difficile
d'être seul dans une classe ou
quelquefois des élèves les contestent
pas partout bien sûr mais il faut les
aider il faut les donc ça veut dire quoi
mieux former les professeurs revoir
aussi les programmes qui sont enseignés
en histoire géograph fa former les
professeurs il faut que la les
hiérarchies les soutiennent il faut leur
donner des moyens il faut changer un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui ne
vont pas dans les écoles les dans les
établissements les plus dans dans les
villes les plus défavorisées sont pas
forcément les écoles qui ont le plus de
moyens ça c'est déjà normal vous
comprenez donc les profs ont besoin de
moyens ils ont besoin d'être soutenus
ils ont besoin d'être défendus ils ont
besoin d'être encouragé et c'est très
important et la dernière chose que
j'aimerais dire j'en reviens à la
manifestation parce que je l'ai devant
les yeux avec mes camarades c'est le
plus beau dé mentis au twite incendiaire
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a osé écire
cette insanité les amis du soutien
inconditionnel au massacre ont leur
rendez-vous non les amis de la
République sont au rendez-vous et lui
c'est l'amis de de l'insanité de la
bêtise Galina Elbas ce sursaut
républicain il a eu lieu aujourd'hui oui
il a eu lieu et il faut s'en réjouir la
la France était est au rendez-vous de de
ce grand rassemblement civique de lutte
contre l'antisémitisme j'ai envie de
dire de lutte contre toutes les haines
il y a une phrase importante qui qui me
tient à cœur qui est le slogan que la
Licra défend et je suis de la couleur de
celui qu'on persécute aujourd'hui les
Français se sont dit qu'ils étaient de
la couleur des Juifs français persécutés
depuis un mois et qui sont l'objet d'une
recrut descence d'acte épouvantable un
tout petit mot sur les solutions sur au
plan judiciaire j'entendais tout à
l'heure qu'effectivement face au
déferlement de de haine sur les réseaux
sociaux qui aujourd'hui se manifeste par
des propos apologie éque de terrorisme
il faut absolument contrôler la parole
de haine sur les réseaux sociaux on a
une réponse simple que l'on cesse de
pronner à la Licra depuis quelques
années il faut absolument sortir les
discours de haine raciste et antisémite
de la loi qui protège les journalistes
c'est-à-dire vous vous êtes de la
liberté de la presse ce continuum entre
haine antisémitisme et liberté
journalistique alimente l'idée qu'être
raciste et antisémite c'est de l'opinion
quasi journaliste alors que c'est un
délit hein il faut Rapp alors que c'est
un délit et on a des apprentis
journalistes sur les réseaux sociaux qui
ne cessent de pérorer sur leur haine et
qu'il se pense à l'abri de toute
sanction je ne dis pas que la loi sur la
presse ne permet pas de sanctionner mais
et c'est fort judicieux à l'époque où
elle a été créée elle permettait de
protéger le pouvoir que vous
journalistique enfin le contrepouvoir
j'ai envie de dire journalistique pour
apporter à cette notre
démocratie des moyens de se défendre
aussi grâce à votre parole il faut
changer la loi il faut que c'est délire
entre Dr le droit commun pour qu'il
puisse être mieux ce débat a eu lieu il
y a quelques mois à l'assemblé nation pe
lieu mais il a qu même des lobbyes des
lobes que ce soit que ce soit et chez
les avocats et chez les spécialistes du
droit de la presse qui militent pour que
ce ne soit pas le cas il faut que c'est
délirante dans le code pénal général qui
puisse être poursuivi rapidement et avec
efficacité et comme il se doit il s'agit
pas de liberté d'expression ou d'opinion
il s'agit de discours de haine qui
doivent être sanctionnés rapidement ce
qui av été fait en 2014 sur l'apologie
contre tout à fait la poologie du
terrorisme a été est un délit de droit
commun et ce qui permet son efficacité
de poursuite devant les juridictions
notamment en comparition immédiate ce B
on a beaucoup parlé de la présence de
l'antisémitisme sur les réseaux sociaux
euh dans quel P de la société
l'antisémitisme est-il encore le plus
présent selon vous il n'est pas que sur
les réseaux non bien sûr et quand on
pose la question aux Français de
confession juifes qui ont déjà
expérimenté un acte antisémite déjà
c'est une grande majorité d'entre eux il
faut le souligner c'est 75 % le premier
lieu d'expérience antisémite en France
c'est l'école et c'est pour ça qu'on j'y
revenait et que d'autres y sont revenus
c'est c'est vraiment fondamamental et
ensuite quand on pose la question aux
Français dans leur ensemble avez-vous
déjà vu autour de vous des actes des
paroles antisémites c'est aussi une
grande majorité de Français qui ont déjà
observé ça autour d'eux et là quand on
leur demande où ce qui reçoivent en
premier c'est les réseaux sociaux donc
donc c'est voilà on a bien fait d'en
parler mais sur dans dans le monde réel
l'école est vraiment primordiale et
ensuite on a le les lieux publics tout
simplement où où où ont lieu les
agressions et cetera mais le cadre
scolaire aussi le cadre périscolaire est
un lieu de de de manifestation d'un Jeur
antisémite et il faut s'attaquer à ce
secteur là Annesophie Seban vous êtes
directrice de l'American Jewish commite
à Paris on a vu que ce
mouvement cet antisémitisme ce mouvement
proalestinien il se développait beaucoup
aussi aux
États-Unis on a vu cette cette recru
d'esence aussi contre les Juifs est-ce
que vous pensez que le mouvement wiste
de l'opprim contre le le colonisateur
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il joue un
rôle dans le le conflit aujourd'hui
israëlo-palestinien il joue un rôle dans